TESTING ONE TWO THREE ALL GOOD
BEAUTIFUL. GOOD MORNING AND
WELCOME TO THE APRIL TWENTY
NINTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE HEARING
OF THE ASSEMBLY ELECTIONS
COMMITTEE HER. WE'RE GOING TO
BEGIN AS A SUB COMMITTEE IF
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ARE
MONITORING THIS HEARING FROM
THEIR OFFICES PLEASE COME TO
ROOM FOR THIRTY SEVEN. SO THAT
WE CAN ESTABLISH A QUORUM. WE
SEEK TO PROTECT THE RIGHTS OF
ALL WHO PARTICIPATE IN THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS SO THAT WE
CAN HAVE EFFECTIVE DELIBERATION
AND DECISIONS ON THE CRITICAL
ISSUES FACING CALIFORNIA.
THROUGH THE CALL THE PANDEMIC
WE HAVE A LIMITED SPACE FOR THE
PUBLIC TO PARTICIPATE SO WE GET
IN FOR EVERYONE MAINTAINS SIX
FEET OF SOCIAL DISTANCE. THIS
YEAR- TESTERS HAVE APPEARED AT
LEGISLATIVE HEARINGS REMOVING
THEIR MASKS YELLING FROM THE
AUDIENCE AND ISSUING VEILED
THREATS ABOUT POTENTIAL GUN
VIOLENCE AS WE PROCEED WITH THE
WITNESSES AND PUBLIC COMMENT I
WANNA MAKE SURE EVERYONE
UNDERSTANDS OF THE ASSEMBLY HAS
RULES TO ENSURE WE MAINTAIN
ORDER AND RUN AN EFFICIENT AND
FAIR HEARING WE APPLY THESE
RULES TO ALL PEOPLE WHO
PARTICIPATE IN PROCEEDINGS. IN
ADDITION THIS YEAR WE WILL
AGAIN BE COMPLYING WITH ALL
PUBLIC HEALTH ORDERS ARISING
OUT OF THE COVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC IN ORDER TO FACILITATE
THE GOAL OF HEARING AS MUCH
FROM THE PUBLIC WITHIN THE
LIMITS OF OUR TIME WILL NOT
PERMIT CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS
DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE IMPEDE
THE ORDERLY CONDUCT OF
LEGISLATIVE PROCEEDINGS WE WILL
NOT ACCEPT THIS SORT OF
BEHAVIOR OR BEHAVIOR THAT
INCITES OR THREATENS VIOLENCE.
EVEN VEILED THREATS. AS YOU
CAME INTO THE HEARING TODAY THE
SERGEANTS DIRECTED YOUR
ATTENTION TO THE RULES FOR
PUBLIC ATTENDANCE AND
PARTICIPATION IT WOULD FOR
POSTED OUTSIDE THE DOOR. THE
RULES FOR TODAY'S HEARING
INCLUDE WEARING A MASK OVER
YOUR MOUTH AND NOSE AT ALL
TIMES AND COMPLYING WITH
PHYSICAL DISTANCING. NO TALKING
OR LOUD NOISES FROM THE
AUDIENCE. PUBLIC COMMENT MAY BE
PROVIDED ONLY AT THE DESIGNATED
TIME AND PLACE AND IS PERMITTED
BY THE CHAIR. PUBLIC COMMENT
MUST RELATE TO THE BILL BEING
DISCUSSED. NO ENGAGING IN
CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS DISTURBS
OR OTHERWISE IMPEDE THE ORDERLY
CONDUCT OF THIS HEARING. PLEASE
BE AWARE THAT VIOLATIONS OF
THESE RULES MAY SUBJECT YOU TO
REMOVAL OR OTHER ENFORCEMENT
PROCESS. THE COMMITTEE IS EIGHT
BILLS ON ITS AGENDA TODAY AND
THE HEARING IS A HARD STOP TIME
OF ONE THIRTY PM. IN ORDER TO
ALLOW TIME FOR THIS HEARING
ROOM TO BE CLEANED AND ANOTHER
HEARING IN THIS ROOM THIS
AFTERNOON. GIVEN THE TIME
CONSTRAINTS WE WILL NEED TO
LIMIT PUBLIC TESTIMONY AS
FOLLOWS. THERE WILL BE A
MAXIMUM OF TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF EACH
BILL. INTO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO EACH BILL. WITH A
LIMIT OF TWO MINUTES PER
PRIMARY WITNESS. AFTER WE'VE
HEARD FROM THE PRIMARY
WITNESSES. THE PUBLIC WILL HAVE
FIFTEEN MINUTES IN TOTAL TIME
FOR ADDITIONAL PUBLIC COMMENT.
STARTING WITH THOSE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WHO ARE HERE IN THE
ROOM. THESE ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WILL BE STRICTLY
LIMITED TO PROVIDING THEIR
NAME. THE ORGANIZATION THEY
REPRESENT IF ANY. IN THE
POSITION ON THE BILL ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS COMMENTS WILL BE RULED
OUT OF ORDER. I DID NOT MAKE
THE DECISION IMPOSES THOMAS
LIGHTLY HOWEVER GIVEN THE
LIMITED AMOUNT OF TIME THAT
THIS COMMITTEE HAS FOR HEARINGS
IT WAS THE ONLY WAY. THEY WILL
BE ABLE TO SCHEDULE PUBLIC
HEARINGS ON MORE THAN A SMALL
NUMBER OF BILLS. IN THE
COMMITTEE'S JURISDICTION. THIS
YEAR BEFORE I CONTINUE I'D LIKE
TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM A QUORUM.
SO LET'S CALL THE ROLL AND
ESTABLISH A QUORUM MADAM
SECRETARY BERMAN. HERE BERMAN
HERE START GO HERE THERE ARE
TWO YEAR BAN ACT. SENATE
HEARING. MAYES HERE MAYES HERE
MULLIN. RUBIO WE A QUORUM WE
HAVE A CORE THAT IS FANTASTIC.
IF YOU ARE UNABLE TO GET
THROUGH ON THE PHONE PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO SUBMIT WRITTEN
TESTIMONY THROUGH THE PORTAL ON
THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE THIS
WRITTEN TESTIMONY WILL BECOME
PART OF THE OFFICIAL RECORD OF
THE BILL. FOR THOSE WHO ARE
WATCHING THIS HEARING REMOTELY
AND WHO WISH TO CALL IN TO
REGISTER THEIR POSITION THE
CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING
IS. 877-692-8957 AGAIN THAT'S.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN AGAIN
THAT IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE
FOUR THREE SEVEN. YOU CAN ALSO
FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY ELECTIONS COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON YOUR TV
OR COMPUTER SCREEN. IF YOU WERE
CALLING IN PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE THIS INCLUDES
MUTING YOUR LIVESTREAM
BROADCAST AND YOUR SMART
DEVICES. TO REDUCE THE SOUND
DISTORTION. IF YOU'RE HAVING
ANY ROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATED
PHONE SERVICE. YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE SIX.
THREE ONE NINE. TWO ZERO NINE
FOUR. AND MY STAFF WILL BE
THERE TO TRY TO HELP. THANK YOU
FOR BEING WITH US AS WE
IMPLEMENT METHODS TO CONTINUE
TO SERVE THE PUBLIC PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. WHILE ALSO BEING
MINDFUL AND RESPECTFUL OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS. WE
FACE. WITH ALL THOSE
ANNOUNCEMENTS OUT OF THE WAY WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO THE
COMMITTEE'S AGENDA. LET'S TAKE
OF THE COMMITTEE'S CONSENT
CALENDAR. THERE IS ONE BILL ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR I WAS
HOPING TO HAVE MORE THAN ONE
BILL ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
BUT WE HAVE ONE BILL. ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR THAT BILL IS
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT. AB FIFTEEN
NINETY ONE. BY THE ASSEMBLY
ELECTIONS COMMITTEE. DOES ANY
MEMBER WITH TO REMOVE AN ITEM
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE DO WE
HAVE A MOTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR I MOVED TO. GOT A
MOTION BY THE VICE CHAIR A
SECOND BY MISTER BENNETT- MADAM
SECRETARY WILL YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR TO MOTIONS TO PASS
WITH THE RECOMMENDATION TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR BERMAN HI.
BERMAN I SAY YOUR TOTAL NINE C.
R. TELL I SENATE. SENATE I LOW.
MAYES MAYES I'M MORE. LOCKER
ROOM. THAT BILL IS OUT WITH THE
BILL HAS A FOR ZERO VOTE IT
WILL KEEP THE OPEN FOR MEMBERS.
ONE NOW MOVE ON TO THE OTHER
BILLS ON THE COMMITTEE'S AGENDA-
WOULD LOVE TO HAVE. AUTHOR IS
NOT ON THE COMMITTEE IF WE HAVE
ANY AUTHORS NOT ON THE
COMMITTEE THAT ARE STOLEN FOR
ANY REASON PLEASE STOP INCOME
TO ROOM WHAT WE FOR THIRTY
SEVEN. FOUR THIRTY SEVEN TO
PRESENT YOUR BILLS- NOT SEEING
ANY. AUTHOR IS NOT ON THE
COMMITTEE I BELIEVE MR MAYES
YOU HAVE SOME BILLS WOULD YOU
LIKE TO PRESENT YOUR BILLS.
WHAT WHEN WE GET ANYBODY NOT
FROM THE COMMITTEE PLEASE GO
AHEAD- WALL WALL WILL PUT YOUR
OF NEXT SO COME ON DOWN DON'T
BE SHY. WE'RE FUND GROUP. WE
BROUGHT. MR MAYS WOULD YOU LIKE
TO PRESENT ON YOU PICK YOU
PICK- LET'S GO WITH THE FIRST
ONE FOR TWENTY EIGHT AB FOUR
TWENTY EIGHT WHEN YOU'RE READY
SIR THANK YOU AB. FOR TWENTY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
THE COMMITTEE APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY BEFORE
YOU TODAY. I AM A BI FOR TWENTY
EIGHT EIGHT BEFORE TWENTY EIGHT
IS RATHER SIMPLE AND STRIKES AT
THE CORE OF OUR DEMOCRATIC
INSTITUTIONS WE MUST ENSURE.
OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
STRUCTURED IN A WAY THAT LEAST
THE BEST ELECTED REPRESENTATION
POSSIBLE. THIS BILL GUARANTEES
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR COUNTY
SUPERVISORS BY ALLOWING THEM TO
STAND FOR REELECTION AND GAIN
EXPERTISE OF THE JOB THROUGH A
MINIMUM. OF TWO ELECTED TERMS
IN OFFICE. WILL ALSO CONTINUE
TO ALLOW THEM ADEQUATE
COMPENSATION IS LAID OUT IN THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION SO WE
HAVE QUALIFIED CANDIDATES FROM
ALL WALKS OF LIFE. THAT ARE NOT
JUST INDEPENDENTLY WEALTHY. BUT
THE WITH THE WATERS SURROUND
THIS BILL HAVE BEEN MUDDIED.
INCLUDING A IN A FUNDAMENTALLY
FUNDAMENTALLY INCORRECT LETTER
SUBMITTED BY THE OPPOSITION.
JERRY BERMAN IF IT'S ALRIGHT
WITH YOU I'D LIKE TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO SET THE RECORD
STRAIGHT PLEASE AB FOUR TWENTY
EIGHT. DOES NOT CONTAIN IT
RETROACTIVE CLAUSE. NOR WILL I
ALLOW ONE TO BE AMENDED INTO
THE BILL THEREFORE THIS BILL
DOES NOT DIRECTLY OVERTURN ANY
LOCAL MEASURE NOR IS IT
SUPPOSED TO. HOWEVER THERE WAS
A RECENT LOCAL MEASURE THAT
HIGHLIGHTED A DEFICIENCY IN
STATE LAW. THAT WE MUST ADDRESS
RESULTING IN THIS BILL BEFORE
THAT BEFORE ALL OF US TODAY.
THIS BILL CONTAINS. ONE
SUBSTANTIVE CHANGE WOULD SET
THE FLOOR OF A MINIMUM OF TWO
TERMS FOR COUNTY SUPERVISORS IN
COUNTY ORDINANCES OR
INITIATIVES. AND ONE TECHNICAL
CHANGE CLARIFYING THE COUNTY
SUPERVISORS ARE THEMSELVES
OFFICERS AS REFLECTED ARTICLE
LEVIN. SECTION ONE OF THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION. AS
MENTIONED IN THE ANALYSIS. THE
CONSTITUTION EXPLICITLY%
PROVIDES THE COMPENSATION
COUNTY OFFICERS. INCLUDING THE
MEMBERS OF THE GOVERNINGBODY
ELECTED COUNTY SHERIFF ELECTED
DISTRICT ATTORNEY ELECTED
ASSESSOR. AND ANY OTHER OFFICES
CREATED BY THE BOARD SHALL BE
PRESCRIBED ORDINANCE AND THE
NEW ORLEANS PRESCRIBING SUCH
COMPENSATION. SHALL BE SUBJECT
TO REFERENDUM. I AM JOINED
TODAY BY THE HER SOME OF THE-
URBAN COUNTIES ACCOUNT. AS WELL
THE SECTOR DAY. ABOUT THE
JOINED BY TWO BRENNAN THE
BEHALF OF S. THANK YOU SURE.
THANK YOU MISTER MAY- AND WE
WILL MOVE TO- G. HEARST FROM
THE URBAN COUNTIES ACCOUNT JUST
OVER MY OF TWO. AND I BELIEVE
YOUR THING YOU. PERFECT BY
PHONE. THANK YOU I THINK MISTER
CHAIR AT MEMBERS- GENE HER HERE
THIS MORNING OF THE OF THE
URBAN OF. COAST OF THE STATE
FOURTEEN THE MOST POPULOUS
COUNTY. IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
MEANS THAT EIGHT TWENTY. OUT
WHICH WOULD ENSURE THAT ON
APPROACH BE THAT CALIFORNIA
COUNTY BOARD OF DEEPER BUT ARE
SUBJECT TO A TERM LIMIT WHETHER
BAKER CHARTER OR BRIGHT ARE
ELIGIBLE A MINUTE A FEW. AND
CLEAR I THINK THE THING LAW
THAT THE OF SUPERVISORS ON THE
FOR WRITING CONTENT COMPENSATE
FOR ALL COUNTY OFF IN THE BOY
THEMSELVES. WE TRY SUPPORT THIS
CHANGE IN FACT. TO ENSURE AN
APPROPRIATE LESS OF. THE OFFICE
ACCOUNT TO PROVIDE. A LEVEL OF
EXPERTISE AND ACCOUNTED. ARE
AND THE COURT. ABOUT THAT CAN
HELLO CAN BE- CAN YOU TO
PROVIDERS AND CAL. THAT MAKES
AND ALSO UNDERSCORES THE NEED
FOR APPROPRIATE TIME TO ALLOW
THE PROVIDER TO GAIN EXPERIENCE
IN MANAGING WHAT IS AN
INCREASINGLY COMPLEX THAT OF
SERVICE OBLIGATIONS AND
FINANCIAL RESPONSIBILITY. A
SINGLE TURN SIMPLY DOES NOT
ALLOW FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF
SUCH EXPERTISE. AND AS A RESULT
OUR MEMBERS ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
WHAT A SINGLE TERM LIMIT WOULD
MEAN FOR COUNTY POLICY MAKING
AND SERVICE PROVISION AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL. CHINESE TO PROVIDE
THEIR TAKE THEIR
RESPONSIBILITIES SERIOUSLY AND
ALSO ACKNOWLEDGE THE TIME
REQUIRED TO DEVELOP EXPERTISE
AND UNDERSTANDING OF THE WIDER
RANGE. OF THE BALL. AS A RESULT
WE RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE ON EIGHTY FOUR TWENTY
EIGHT TODAY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MS HURST AND NEXT UP I
BELIEVE WE HAVE TERRY BRENNAN
FROM SEIU- MY NOTES SAY THAT
TERRY'S IN. THE PERSON BUT I
DON'T SEE TERRY TERRY ON THE
PHONE. MAYBE TERRY WASN'T
EXPECTING US TO BE DOING THIS
BILL AS QUICKLY YEAH THAT'S
WHAT THE OF MY GUESS SIR TERRY
JOINS US DO WALL WHILE WE'RE
STILL TAKING WITNESS TESTIMONY
WILL MAKE SURE TO A LOT OF CARE
THE CHANCE TO. THE- TESTIFY IN
THE MEANTIME- LET'S. GO TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITE PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. I
BELIEVE WE HAVE SCOTT KAUFMAN
FROM THE HOWARD JARVIS
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION BY PHONE.
HI YES ACTUALLY COULD WE ALLOW-
COMMERCE YOU CAN READ BURNING
GROUP TO GO FIRST GLADLY KIND
OF LEVEL WITH YOUR RECALLS
PREFERENCE TALK WE HAVE TOM
MURPHY FROM THE RED RUNNING
GROUPS WILL BE TESTIFYING FIRST
AGAIN REMINDER TOM GOT TWO
MINUTES. VERY GOOD. AB BOARD
TWENTY EIGHT ASSEMBLY ANOTHER
SKIRMISH IN A LOCAL POLITICAL
BATTLE. THIS CONFLICT HAS RAGED
IN SAMBAR DINO COUNTY SINCE TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE. RICHARD MELL
THE POLITICAL ELITE OF THE
COUNTY PROPOSED A ONE SIZE FITS
ALL LEGISLATIVE SOLUTION FOR
THE ENTIRE STATE. IN TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE REFORM MEASURE
SPONSORED BY RED DESPERATE IT
WAS APPROVED BY 64% OF THE
VOTERS. HOWEVER THE POLITICAL
ESTABLISHMENT PRESENTED THEIR
COMPETING MANAGER. THAT PASSED
BY 67% IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN OUR ORGAN. HAVE FOR
SEPARATE GOOD FOR AND- THE
POLITICAL. SUED US ON TWELVE
WE'RE SO FIGHTING THIS COURT
WHAT MAJOR DID IT THROUGH THE
NOVEMBER TWO VOTE AND DINO
COUNTY APPROVED MAJOR BY MORE
THAN TWO TO VOTE. MAJOR CASE OF
SUPER SALARY ON WITH THE NEW
HOW FOR IN IN THIS. POOR COUNTY.
IT ALSO SET ONE FOUR YEAR TERM
OF SERVICE TO AN ELECTED
OFFICIAL COULD FOCUS ON
GOVERNING. MANEUVERING FOR
REELECTION. RATHER THAN ACCEPT
THE WILL OF THE VOTERS AGREE
FASHION DUTIES ACCORDING TO
VOTER INTO. DECEMBER COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS WENT TO
BATTLE AGAINST THEIR OWN
CONSTITUENTS. INSERTING
BREATHTAKING AUDACITY THE BOARD
USE TAXPAYER FUNDING AND TO
HOLD IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
INITIATIVE THAT WAS JUST
APPROVED BY THOSE VERY SAME
TAXPAYERS. AB FOUR TO EIGHT IS
NOTHING BUT SOUR GRAPES FROM
THE POLITICAL ESTABLISHMENT
DECEMBER DINO KALE. IN ORDER TO
**** **** VICTORY FROM THE JAWS
OF REFORM THEY PROPOSED TO
IMPOSE THEIR LOCAL SOLUTION ON
THE ENTIRE STATE. EIGHTY FOUR
TWENTY SHOULD BE ROUNDLY
REJECTED. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER MURPHY AND
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO MISTER
KAUFMAN. THANK YOU. TIMBRE
DEALS MEASURE K<c.cyan> TWO THINGS</c>
IT AMENDED THE SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY CHARTER TO SET TOTAL
COMPENSATION FOR EACH MEMBER OF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS TO
FIVE THOUSAND PER MONTH.
UNLIMITED MEMBERS TO A ONE FOUR
YEAR TERM TURN. AB FOUR TO
EIGHT THOSE TWO THINGS IMPOSE A
LIMIT OF NO FEWER THAN TWO
TERMS AND SPECIFY THE BORE
SUPERVISORS AND IS INCLUDED IN
THE DEFINITION OF COUNTY
OFFICERS. FOR WHOM THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IS REQUIRED TO
PRESCRIBE COMPENSATION. THE
INTENT OF AB FOUR TO EIGHT IT'S
CLEAR NO MORE MEASURE CASE THE
PROPONENTS OF THIS BILL BELIEVE
MEDICAID A PROBLEM. BUT IT'S NO
WORSE THAN STRIPPING VOTER
STATEWIDE OF THE ABILITY TO
DESIGNATE THEIR PREFERRED
LENGTH OF TERMS AND SET PAY OF
THE COUNTY SUPERVISORS BECAUSE
WE DON'T LIKE THE OUTCOME OF AN
ELECTION. ARTICLE TWO SECTION
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
CONSTITUTION SAYS ALL POLITICAL
POWER IS INHERENT IN THE PEOPLE
THEY HAVE THE RIGHT TO ALTER OR
REFORM IT WHEN THE PUBLIC GOOD
MAY REQUIRE. THE PEOPLE OF
SAMBAR DINO COUNTY EXERCISE
THEIR RIGHT TO INITIATIVE AND
ALTER THE COUNTY CHARTER. AB
FOUR TO EIGHT ATTEMPTS TO
SUBVERT THIS BOOK REFORM
EFFORTS SANCTIONED BY THE STATE
CONTROLLING LEGAL DOCUMENT BY
ALTERING THE CODE IN A WAY THAT
PREVENTS BOATERS AND ANY OTHER
COUNTY FROM DOING THE SAME IF
MEASURE K. THIS IS NOT THE
PROPER RESPONSE TO A LAWFUL
VOTE OF THE PEOPLE. WE ALSO
REMAIN UNCONVINCED THAT AB FOUR
TO EIGHT WOULD NOT HAVE ANY
EFFECT ON THE IMPLEMENTATION
BETTER CANE TEMPER AND DINO AND
WE HAVE TO VOTE NO. ON AB FOUR
TO EIGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER COUGH. WE NOW GOING TO.
UP THE LINE- WE'RE GONNA SEE
THERE ARE WITNESS. IN THE
HEARING ROOM. SEEING AND
HEARING NINE AND WE'RE GOING TO
GO TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC.
BUT FIRST- I BELIEVE MR BRENNAN.
IS CALLING IN TO THE PUBLIC
LINE SO. OFFER OPERATOR IF YOU
CAN. IF WE CAN GET MISTER
BRENNAN AND TO- TO BE ABLE TO
GO FIRST FOR TWO MINUTES THAT
WOULD BE IDEAL. IF WE'RE NOT
ABLE TO DO THAT THEN WHENEVER
MISTER BURNS TIME COMES UP
WE'LL MAKE SURE THAT. THAT HE
GETS TWO MINUTES. OPERATOR.
YEAH MISTER BRANDON IF YOU ARE
ON THE CALL PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. THANK YOU. AND
CURRENTLY NOT SEEN HIS LINE AT
THIS POINT OKAY IF HE IT
WHENEVER HE ARRIVES WILL MAKE
SURE TO GIVE IN TWO MINUTES AS
LONG AS MISTER BROWN AND- YOU
IDENTIFIES HIMSELF IN THE
MEANTIME LET'S OPEN IT UP FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT. PROCON WHEREVER
IN A REMINDER WE HAVE FIFTEEN
MINUTES OF PUBLIC COMMENT.
CERTAINLY THIS IS YOUR MIND IF
YOU DO HAVE A PUBLIC COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO IN
THE FIRST WITH A LINE OF SIXTY
SIX SIX SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS NICOLE BORNEMANN ON
BEHALF OF SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND THAT
WAS A TEXTBOOK WAY TO DO THIS I
FORGOT TO REMIND EVERYBODY
PLEASE PROVIDE YOUR NAME. YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION
ON THE BILL I NOTHING MORE
UNLESS YOU'RE MISTER BRENNAN.
THANK YOU. NEXT WELL TO A LINE
NUMBER EIGHTY TWO EIGHTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. EIGHTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES EUROPE. I MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JERRY BROWN
AND I HEARD A GUY NO WORRIES
TERRY. WHICH MAKE THEIR MADE IN
THE BEGINNING ALL OF THAT THE
CAR YOU WENT. IT THANK YOU SO
MUCH- YOU DON'T GIVE ME- IF YOU
KNOW YOU TELL SUPPORT- A. B.
FOR TWELVE EIGHT- AT YOUR AGE
WHAT NE WE GET ON ALSO SHOULD
BE TERM LIMITS ISSUE GENERALLY
SUPPORTING TERM LIMITS. IN OF
THE KIDS HAVE WE EVER TERM
LIMITS. LAST CHIU CHARM- JUST.
IT REQUIRE- BUT IT GOVERNMENT
AND PUBLIC- REQUIRED THEY YOU
HAVE MORE. THAN EARNING OVER
LEADERSHIP EVERY YEAR. AND I
THINK IT'S CLEAR FROM THE THAT
WHAT YOU GOT IN THE END THAT
CHIU THINGS AGAIN ALL YOUR
MEASURE K. A COURT CASE. OR
WHAT- TO THE PEOPLE YOU CAN DO
IT WITH THE BILL. THAT REASON
THAT WE SHOULD YEAH AB TWENTY
EIGHT- DR- THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER BROWN AND
APPRECIATE THAT. WE WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
WHEN THIS TEST AND SUPPORT OF-
NAY. ORGANIZATION OF THIS ON
THE BILL THANKS. AND THAT'S
WHAT NUMBER SIX TWO SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES HI OF ME TO- MY
IS LARRY BURROW AND MY WORK IN
A DAY IS THE THEM. OF THE THING
GABRIEL VALLEY- WE SUPPORT BILL
STRONGLY AB TWENTY AND URGE YOU
TO PASS IT OUT OF COMMITTEE. SO
THANK YOU I BELIEVE YOU'RE
CALLING FOR THE WRONG BILL JUST
A REMINDER FOR EVERYBODY ON THE
TELEPHONES AB FOUR TWENTY
EIGHT. IS A BILL WE ARE
DISCUSSING RIGHT NOW THE- A. B.
TWENTY I THINK WILL BE UP NEXT-
THE AUTHOR OF AB TWENTY IS IN
THE HEARING ROOM SO ASSUMING HE
DOESN'T HAVE TO GO ANYWHERE.
THAT BILL WILL BE NEXT- BUT
RIGHT NOW WE'RE DOING A BEFORE
TWENTY EIGHT. BY CHAD MAYES WE
WILL GO TO ONE. THANK YOU ON
THE LINE SIXTY FIVE SIX FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. N. LINE SIXTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LET'S
MOVE ON AND WE WILL LOOK TO
LINES WILL WILL DECLINE SEVENTY
EIGHT THANK YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING STACEY HEAT WITH
THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING THIRTY SEVEN RURAL
COUNTIES STATEWIDE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. M. S. CHAIR AND NO
FURTHER COMMENTS IN Q. THANKS.
LET'S ALSO QUICKLY GO TO THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION TO SEE
IF THERE'S ANY REMOTE TESTIMONY
FOR THIS BILL. LOOKING AT A
BLANK BLACK SCREEN I'M GOING TO
ASSUME THERE'S NO REMOTE
TESTIMONY FOR THE BILL- SO WITH
THAT LET'S BRING IT BACK TO
COLLEAGUES. FOR ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS ON A BEFORE TWENTY
EIGHT. LOOKING FOR QUESTIONS
COMMENTS MOTION SECONDS MISTER
ROYSTER. PLEASE YEAH THIS IS
THIS HOW DIFFICULT BILL FOR ME
BECAUSE IT HAS THERE'S TWO
PRINCIPLES INVOLVED HERE. ONE
OF THEM IS THE WILL OF THE
VOTERS. AND IN IN THE OTHER ONE
IS MY CONCERN FOR FUNCTIONING
GOVERNMENT. AND YOU KNOW
UNFORTUNATELY OVER THE YEARS
I'VE SEEN LOTS OF WILL OF THE
VOTER VOTES THAT ARE IMPOSED ON
CITIES AND COUNTIES AND
LOCALITIES. DETER DETER
DAMAGING. TO THE SERVICES THAT
THEY THEY GET. BUT I ALSO FEEL
LIKE AND THAT'S WHAT THEY CHOSE
AND TRYING TO GO OVER THE WILL
OF THE VOTERS IS A DIFFICULT
THING- FOR THIS I REALLY FEEL
LIKE- THE I I'M I'M SUPER ON
THE FENCE BECAUSE- AT THE.
TRYING TO A LIKE I SAID TRYING
TO. GO AGAINST THE WILL OF THE
VOTERS CREATES THIS DISSENSION
IN IN A COMMUNITY OR IN IT I
THINK AND I THINK THIS IS MORE
OF A- GOVERNMENT BY GOVERNMENT
THING NOT A STATE WIDE THING
THAT SHOULD BE IMPOSED ON
EVERYBODY- IF. YOU WANT COUNTY
WANTS TO RUIN THEIR GOVERNMENT
AND THEY CITIES I MEAN THEY CAN
PEOPLE THAT'S WHAT THEY VOTE
FOR. THE GUY CARE ACT TO LIVE
WITH IT. IN IN WITHIN ONE.
POINT OF VIEW. YEAH AND THEN
YOU KNOW MAYBE THEY FIGURE OUT
THAT WHILE. EVERYBODY'S PASSING
US BY. N. N. AND THEN MAYBE
THEY GET OLD YOU KNOW THEY DO
SOMETHING TO FIX THAT. ARE IN
THERE IS ALSO THE COURT WAY OF
DOING IF THERE'S TOO MUCH
DAMAGE IT'S GOING TO BE DONE
AND I KNOW ONE CASE THAT.
THAT'S KIND OF WHERE THE CITY
LANDED ONCE. WE'RE NOT DOING
THAT BECAUSE THIS IS JUST GOING
TO. CREATE TOO MUCH DAMAGE. SO-
YOU KNOW I'M I'M- PROBABLY
GONNA LAY OFF YOUR BILL TODAY-
AND- WE CAN- FURTHER DISCUSSION
ON THE FLOOR. THANKS WHAT IF I
CAN'T- YEAH MISTER TERRITORY
ACTUALLY WHAT YOU JUST
REFERENCE I STRUGGLE WITH THOSE
VERY SAME THINGS AND BY THE
WAY- YOU AND I AREN'T THE FIRST
TO STRUGGLE WITH THIS IF YOU GO
BACK. TO THE BEGINNING OF OUR
THAT THE FOUNDATION OF OUR OF
OUR OF OUR GOVERNMENT THESE ARE
THE DEBATES THAT OUR FOUNDERS
HAD IN REGARDS TO HOW HOW MANY
YEARS. UNITED STATES SENATORS-
SHOULD HAVE VERSUS HOW MANY
YEARS THAT THE MEMBERS OF THE
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES HAVE
HOW MUCH- INFLUENCE WE HAVE-
DIRECTLY FROM THE PEOPLE AND
HOW MUCH SHOULD THERE BE THAT
THE INSTITUTIONS. AS YOU AS YOU
KNOW- OUR INSTITUTIONS- OVER
THE LAST THIRTY YEARS HAVE.
BEEN UNDER DIRECT ASSAULT FROM
THE BY ALL SORTS OF DIFFERENT.
DIFFERENT GROUPS- AND THAT
THESE DEBATES ABOUT- A BIG
GOVERNMENT BY THE PEOPLE AND
ALSO HAVING A CONSTITUTIONAL
REPUBLIC- IS A IS SOMETHING
REAL- YOU HER OUT WHERE I COME
DOWN ON THIS- AND YOU'LL
UNDERSTAND THIS BECAUSE YOU
SERVED IN LOCAL LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS I THINK ALMOST
EVERYBODY ON THIS COMMITTEE-
SERVED IN. IN LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
HANFORD WHEN I SUCH FOUR YEARS
OLD DELAY WHEN I WAS TWENTY
FIVE AND- ALTHOUGH I HAD GOTTEN
A DEGREE IN POLITICAL SCIENCE
AND GOVERNMENT. AND THOUGHT I
HAD ALL THE ANSWERS- I REALIZE
VERY QUICKLY- THAT- I DID NOT
KNOW WHAT I WAS TALKING ABOUT-
AND I REMEMBER I WOULD GET THE
AGENDA PACKETS. FOR CITY
COUNCIL AND I'D GET THEM WE HAD
TUESDAY NIGHT MEETINGS I'D GET
HIM. I USUALLY THURSDAY OR
FRIDAY AND I SPENT ALL WEEKEND
READING EVERY SINGLE WORD OF
THAT AGENDA PACKET. INTEL THE
I'D GET TO THE COUNCIL AND I
REALIZED THAT IT TOOK ME A GOOD
THREE YEARS. ON THAT COUNCIL TO
REALLY UNDERSTAND. THE
DECISIONS THAT I WAS MAKING IT
PROBABLY TOOK FIVE YEARS.
BEFORE I REALLY SORT OF GRASS
THAT THE DECISION THAT I MADE
OF THE IMPACT THEY HAVE I THINK
ALL OF YOU PROBABLY HAD. A THAT
THAT THAT SPRINT'S IF YOU'RE
HONEST WITH WITH YOURSELVES. A
YUCCA VALLEY THIS IS THE CITY
THAT I WAS A CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER I HAD FIFTY EMPLOYEES-
IS A POPULATION OF TWENTY ONE
THOUSAND PEOPLE. IT WAS A
CONTRACT- CONTRACT CITY THAT
CONTRACTED OUT FOR FIRE. AND
POLICE AND IT TOOK ME THREE
YEARS- AND WE REALLY FIVE YEARS
TO REALLY FULLY UNDERSTAND THE
DECISIONS I WAS MAKING. THE TWO
COUNTIES THAT I REPRESENT BOTH
REPRESENT MORE THAN TWO MILLION
PEOPLE. ON ONE OF THOSE
COUNTIES THAT BUT THAT WE- WE
BOTH THOUGHT WE BOTH SERVE-
THAT BUDGETS THAT ARE IN THE
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS. ARE THEY
HAVE EMPLOYEES NORTH OF TWENTY
THOUSAND. THE RESPONSIBILITY
THAT THOSE THE BORDER DIRECTORS
HAVE. IS SIGNIFICANT AND TO
THINK TO THINK. THAT YOU CAN
ONLY SERVE- THAT THE AVERAGE.
TIME FOR THAT FIVE MEMBER BOARD
OF DIRECTORS IS EITHER ONE AND
A HALF YEARS. OR TWO AND A HALF
YEARS. I FIND IT TO BE-
DISASTROUS. AND SO THE THING
BEFORE US TODAY. IN GOING
PERSPECTIVE ON TO MAKE SURE
THAT WITH ABUNDANTLY CLEAR
BECAUSE THE OPPOSITION I THINK
KEEPS REFERENCING. ONE
PARTICULAR ONE PARTICULAR
COUNTY THIS ABOUT GOING GOING
FORWARD IT'S NOT TURNING BACK
THE WILL. OF THE PEOPLE I
WOULDN'T. I WOULDN'T SUPPORT
SOMETHING LIKE THAT. THIS IS
ABOUT. GOING FORWARD AND SAYING
LISTEN- A FOR. FOUR THESE
POWERFUL POSITIONS BEING THE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS. WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S
AT LEAST AT LEAST TWO TERMS SO.
YEAH ONE. YEAH THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER MAYES GOT A MOTION
IN THE BACK GOT A SECOND GOT A
BUNCH OF COMMENTS AND JUST
WANNA REMIND EVERYBODY GOT A
PACKED AGENDA AND A LOT OF TIME
MISTER BENNETT PLEASE GREATER
CERTAINLY TRY TO RESPECT THAT
THE REQUESTED TIME I REALLY
APPRECIATE DAY HEARING- THAT MY
COLLEAGUE IS- STILL ON THE
FENCE- IN AND I AND I
APPRECIATE THE ATTENTION TO
THOSE OUT THERE IN TERMS OF
OVERTURNING OF OVER THE PEOPLE
THIS IS HAVING THE TRUST OF THE
PUBLIC IS IMPORTANT. BUT I
WOULD HAVE OF THE JUST LIKE THE
OFFER THIS AS YOUR ON THE
FENCE- ON THIS ISSUE AND THAT
IS THAT FUNDAMENTALLY WE'RE
HERE TO DO GOOD GOVERNMENT AND
TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT WHAT IS
GOOD GOVERNMENT AND THEN DO IT
AND OFTENTIMES ONE OF THE
FACTORS IS MAINTAINING THE
TRUST OF THE PEOPLE AS WE DO
THAT BUT THERE. BUT ULTIMATELY
IF YOU'RE IF YOU'RE IF YOU'RE
IN A CLOSE CALL AND YOU GO THIS
IS GOOD GOVERNMENT BUT THE
PEOPLE VOTED FOR THIS WHEN I
HEARD YOU SAY HEY IF THEY WANT
TO RUIN THEIR COUNTY GO AHEAD I
SIT THERE AND TAKE A LOOK AT
ALL THE PEOPLE THAT WOULD BE
HEARD WHILE THEY RUIN THEIR
COUNTY THEY DIDN'T HAVE A VOICE
THAT FOSTER KID THAT DOESN'T
ACTUALLY HAVE ANYBODY SHOW UP-
WHEN. WHEN THERE'S A PROBLEM
BECAUSE THE COUNTY. GIVE WASN'T
MANAGE PROPER EXCEPT FOR SELF.
WHEN I'M FACED WITH THIS
TENSION IT'S ALWAYS YOU HAVE TO
CHOOSE GOOD GOVERNMENT THE
SECOND THING I POINT OUT TO YOU
AS- NEW. WE NEVER GIVE THE
PUBLIC THE RIGHT TO VOTE ON
EVERYTHING. SO WHAT IF THEY
SAID YOU KNOW WE ONE OF THE
ONLY HAVE ONE YEAR IN OFFICE.
WELL THE FOOD WAS SAFELY WILL
WANT TO HAVE SIX MONTHS IN
OFFICE WE WOULDN'T BE ALLOWED
TO DO SOMETHING SO. WHAT WE DO
AT THE STATE LEGISLATIVE LEVEL
HERE WITH REGARDS ELECTIONS IS
SET THIS THE MINIMUM STANDARDS.
AND I THINK IT'S VERY
APPROPRIATE TO HAVE THE MINIMUM
STANDARD BE MORE THAN ONE TERM.
BECAUSE OF THE COMPLEXITY OF
THE JOBS HERE. AND SO WHAT IF
SO T'S NOT LIKE WE'RE- IT MORE
NOT OVERTURNING THE VOTERS.
BECAUSE THIS IS NOT RETROACTIVE
OF THE AUTHOR IS BEING VERY
VERY WISE ABOUT THAT IS NOT.
WHERE WE'RE JUST TELLING THE
VOTERS IN THE FUTURE THIS IS
THE PLAYING FIELD YOU GET TO
VOTE. ANYTHING YOU WANT IT
HERE. BUT IT THESE ARE THE
MINIMUMS RIGHT THAT YOU CAN'T
YOU CAN'T GO BEYOND. AND WITH
THAT I WOULD JUST SAY. THAT I
SUPPORT THE BILL- SECONDING IT-
DOUBLE SECOND GET. WITH WITH MY
COLLEAGUES BUT- I WOULD
ACTUALLY I WANT THE ALSO YOU
KNOW I'VE ACTUALLY FEEL EVEN
BETTER ABOUT THE BILL IF IT WAS
THREE TERMS. BECAUSE I THINK
TWELVE YEARS IS WHAT THE STATE
LEGISLATURES IMPOSED ON ITSELF.
OUR HAS IMPOSED ON THAT I'VE
ACTUALLY SERVE IN A COUNTY THAT
HAS A TWELVE YEAR LIMIT. AND
TWELVE YEARS IS LONG ENOUGH
THAT YOU DON'T HAVE PEOPLE
COMING IN A SUPERVISORS
IMMEDIATELY TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT THEIR NEXT STEP IS.
AND I THINK WHEN YOU GO BELOW
THAT YOU HAVE THAT AS A PROBLEM
SO. IF AS THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD YOU- WANTED TO- AMENDED
TO TWELVE YEARS I CERTAINLY
WOULD BE SUPPORTIVE OF THAT.
BUT I'M ALSO SUPPORTIVE OF THIS
EFFORT IF THAT'S WHAT IF THAT'S
IF THAT'S WHAT'S GOING TO GET
THROUGH. BECAUSE IT'S FAR
BETTER THAN WHERE WE ARE RIGHT
NOW WHERE THEY COULD TAKE IT
DOWN TO ONE. THING AGAIN IF
THANK YOU. WILL MISSOURI. I
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
MAYES- BRINGING THIS AND YOU
KNOW I AM HUGE OF TERM LIMITS-
BUT WITH THE REASON- I WOULD
NOT HAVE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE HERE IF. IF IT WERE NOT FOR
TERM LIMITS BUT PRIOR TO MY
COMING TO THE LEGISLATURE THERE
WAS A SIX YEAR TERM LIMIT TO.
THE ASSEMBLY AND THE WAY I
DESCRIBE IT WAS THE FIRST TWO
YEARS YOU'RE TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT WHERE THE BATHROOM IS THE
SECOND TWO YEARS YOU ACTUALLY
KNOW WHAT YOU'RE DOING ABOUT
THE LAST TWO YEARS FOLKS WERE
ALREADY BUSY TRYING TO RUN FOR
SOMETHING ELSE. AND SO WAS THAT
THE SERVICE FOR THE STATE TO
ONLY HAVE TWO GOOD YEARS OUT OF
A MEMBER NOW THAT WE HAVE
TWELVE YEARS. WE FIGURED OUT
WHERE THE BATHROOM IS THAT NOW
YOU HAVE A SOLID AMOUNT OF
INSTITUTIONAL KNOWLEDGE I THINK
WHAT WAS HAPPENING IN THE STATE
AND I THINK IT'S HAPPENING AND
<c.magenta>OCAL GOVERNMENTS IS. THAT THE</c>
ACTUAL ELECTED OFFICIALS ARE
NOT RUNNING THE STATE I AM THE
ELECTED OFFICIALS ARE NOT
RUNNING THE CITY SAID STAFF
THAT'S RUNNING THE CITIES. AND
SO WE GET INTO A SITUATION
WHERE WHERE IT DOESN'T MATTER-
IF YOU VOTED ME AND IF I'M NOT
ACTUALLY IMPLEMENTINGPOLICIES
THAT ARE GOING TO HELP. AND SO%
FOR ME I YOU KNOW AGAIN I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR THAT BECAUSE
NOW WE'RE LOOKING AT. A SOLID
EIGHT YEARS WHERE FOLKS ARE
GOING TO GET EXACTLY YOU KNOW
GOOD OR BAD- A REPRESENTATIVE
THAT THAT HAS THAT
INSTITUTIONAL KNOWLEDGE AND AT
LEAST HAVE THAT EXPERIENCE TO
MOVE FORWARD SO THANK YOU FOR
THE MEASURE. YOU KNOW I AGREE
WITH MY COLLEAGUE MS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BENNETT TWELVE YEARS
WOULD BE IDEAL. BUT IF EIGHT
YEARS AS SOMETHING THAT THAT-
YOU KNOW IS ONLY. GOING TO GET
THIS THROUGH. YEARS IS A PLENTY
AGAIN INSTITUTIONAL KNOWLEDGE
MATTERS. BUT BUT THE WORK AND
THE- THE EDUCATION THAT WE GET.
IN THAT TIME IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO BE ABLE TO
LEGISLATE OR AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TO BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT OUR LOCAL COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MS RUBIO.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OMMENTS
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I DON'T
THINK I WOULD- ONE. STATE
GUARDS TO THE TWELVE YEARS AGO
ACTUALLY GREET MY COLLEAGUES- I
THINK TWELVE YEARS IS REALLY
SWEET BUT I'M ALSO FACED A
STRONG SUPPORTER OF TERM
LIMITS- I THINK- THAT- JUST FOR
THE- SAKE OF GOOD GOVERNMENT I
THINK HAVING SOME. LIMITS IS
IMPORTANT- BUT UP FOR FOUR
YEARS CERTAINLY ISN'T ISN'T
ENOUGH- IF WE'RE GOING TO AMEND
THE BILL I WOULD WANT TO WORK
WITH THE COMMITTEE- IF WE ARE
GOING TO CHANGE THAT. THIS BILL
COURSE IS GOING TO GET THROUGH
BUT- I HOPE TO BILL TO GET
THROUGH TODAY GET TO THE FLOOR
WOULD GET ITSELF OVER THE
SENATE. BUT JUST BECAUSE IT
MOVES ACROSS THE OTHER HOUSE
DOESN'T MEAN THAT I DON'T WANT
TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH ALL OF
YOU. HOW TO MAKE SURE THAT WE-
WE CONTINUE THE DEBATE AND MAKE
SURE THAT- THAT THAT WE GET IT
RIGHT SO WITH THAT. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE MISTER MISTER CHAIR.
PRETTY SURE THAT- YEAH I
APPRECIATE YOU YOU BRING THIS
BEFORE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION I THINK IT YOU
KNOW AND I'D SAY I AGREE WITH
ALL THE COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE
I MEAN THERE'S- THE INHERENT
CHALLENGES WITH THIS BUT
THERE'S ALSO. YOU KNOW REALLY
GOOD GOVERNANCE TO THE FACT
THAT FOUR YEARS IS FAR TOO
SHORT SO. HAPPEN TO HAVE AYE
RECOMMENDATION- ON ON YOUR BILL
TODAY- AND WOULD ASK THE
SENATOR TO CALL THE VOTE. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BERMAN HI.
BERMAN HIESINGER TELL UMBER
ZERO TWO IS NOT LOADING DOT
NET. SENATE I LOW. FLOW ON
MAYES AYE. MAYES EINMAL. ONE
RUBIO. FOR PROVERBIAL. THAT
BILL IT HAS FIVE VOTES TO FIVE
ZERO TO ONE OF WILL THE ROLE
FOR MEMBERS. LET ME KNOW IF I
GET THAT WORDING WRONG- NEXT UP
WE HAVE I'M MORE ONE ON OUR
AGENDA AB TWENTY BY A SMALL
NUMBER LEAD. GOOD AND WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY SIR RIGHT. I THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TODAY
I'M PRESENTING ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY. THE COVER FOR ELECTIONS
THAT. AND FOR PERSONALIZADO
CHAIR THE MEMBERS ON THIS ISSUE
AREA ON THIS ISSUE IT WAS THE
FIRST BILL I INTRODUCED ON MY
FIRST DAY IN OFFICE AND
SOMETHING THAT I FEEL VERY
PASSIONATELY ABOUT. I THINK
SOMETHING THAT WE ALL HOLD VERY
DEAR AND PUBLIC SERVICES THE
TRUST OF THE PUBLIC THAT IS WHY
I'M DOING THIS BILL BECAUSE I
CANNOT OVERSTATE THAT. IF WE
LOSE THE TRUST OF THE PUBLIC
AND THEY THINK WE ARE
INFLUENCED. BY THE MONEY
RECEIVED AND HOW DECISIONS ARE
MADE. OUR DEMOCRACY COMES INTO
QUESTION AND WOOD THINGS TURN
UGLY OUR DEMOCRACY. AS WIDE
SUPPORT TO BE TO BE DOING THIS
I PERSONALLY. LIVE BY THE MOTTO
THAT YOU KNOW TO PER PREVENT
ANY. APPEARANCE OF INFLUENCE OF
CORPORATE MONEY OR EVEN TO HAVE
THAT EVEN THE BACK OF MY MIND I
VOLUNTARILY OPT OUT OF IT. I
PERSONALLY DO NOT TAKE ANY
CORPORATE MONEY IN ANY FORM.
AND IT'S IMPORTANT TO CONTINUE
THAT TRUST BUT I UNDERSTAND
THAT THESE ARE THE RULES OF THE
GAME. AND THAT WE DID NOT SET
THESE ROLES AND WE TALK AND I
KNOW FROM TALKING MEMBERS WE
DON'T LIKE THE RULES OF THE
GAME. BUT WE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO
ACTIVELY CHANGE THEM SO THAT WE
CAN GET BACK TO WHAT WE WANT TO
DO. TO BE ABLE TO CONNECT
PERSONALLY WITH VOTERS TO BE
ABLE TO TALK TO THEM AND NOT
HAVE TO AUNTS KANSI WORRY
ABOUT. THE OVER BLOATED.
SPENDING ELECTIONS I BEFORE
GOING TO SOME OF OUR BOX I JUST
WANT TO POINT THAT OUT AND I
REALLY AM THANKFUL FOR
ENGAGEMENT OF OUR COLLEAGUES ON
THIS ISSUE. AND I KNOW IT'S NOT
A COMFORTABLE CONVERSATION
ALWAYS BE HAVING BUT I THINK
IT'S SOMETHING THAT ARE THAT
THE PEOPLE KALRA DESERVE- I
JUST WANT TO DRESS SOMETHING
THAT THE ANALYSIS THAT.
SOMETHINGS ARE POINTED OUT
ABOUT. THE DEFINITION OF
BUSINESS ENTITIES OR ABOUT. THE
QUESTION OF WHETHER BUSINESS
HAD THESE KIND. OF ATTACKS. OR
BY CONTRIBUTING POLITICAL
PARTIES. ARE THOSE ARE ALL
THINGS I'D BE OPEN TO IF THE
COMMITTEE WERE TO PROPOSE M. AS
AMENDMENTS I WOULD CERTAINLY BE
OPEN TO IT. BECAUSE I DO WANT
THAT MOST THOROUGH. BILL TO
LIMIT. THE INFLUENCE OF
CORPORATIONS. YOU KNOW TWENTY
TWO OTHER STATES AND THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. CURRENTLY
PROHIBIT DIRECT CONTRIBUTION
FROM CORPORATIONS TO CANADA.
WHAT I'M TRYING TO DO. IS BRING
CALIFORNIA CONFORMITY FOR THE
MOST PART. WITH THE TILLMAN ACT
OF NINETEEN OH SEVEN. IT'S
NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE TO HAVE A
REPRESENT OF DEMOCRACY WITH.
THE WAY OUR CURRENT CAMPAIGN
FINANCE SYSTEM IS SET UP. AND
AS NOTED IN A THIS ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTY FIVE MILLION. WAS
COLLECTED. I WAS COLLECTIVELY
RAISED BY THOSE SEEKING OFFICE
HERE IN SACRAMENTO. 84% OF THAT
EIGHTY. 84% OF THAT ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
WENT TO THE WINNERS. AND OUT OF
THAT ONE IN FOUR DONATIONS 25%
CAME FROM BUSINESS ENTITIES
WHICH MY BILLS SEEKING TO
LIMIT. AND OF THOSE ONE HUNDRED
THIRTY FIVE. I KNOW THAT ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS THAT'S EIGHTY FOUR
PERCENT. WE LOOKED INTO
APPROXIMATELY WHAT. ONE IN FOUR
DOLLARS CAME FROM IS THAT THE-
AND CORPORATIONS IN TWENTY
TWENTY ALONE ACCOUNTED. LIFT
DOOR DASH IN SCAR AND
POSTMATES. ANOTHER GLARING
EXAMPLES THAT PG&E. GAVE A
TOTAL OF TWO POINT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS. BOTH DURING THE
COMPANY'S BANKRUPTCY AND AFTER
PLAYED GUILTY TO EIGHTY FIVE
FELONIES CORPORATE
CONTRIBUTIONS HARM THE ECONOMY
AND ONLY ERODE PUBLIC TRUST IN
US. RATHER IT SHOULD PROVIDE
PEOPLE RATHER OUR OUR-
DEMOCRACY SHOULD BE PROVIDING
PEOPLE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
REPRESENT THE INTERESTS OF THE
COMMUNITIES WITHOUT THE
INFLUENCE OF BIG CORPORATE
MONEY RESEARCH INDICATES THAT
FOR EVERY ONE DOLLAR SPENT IN
BUSINESS CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTIONS
THIS RESULTS IN SIX DOLLARS AND
SIXTY FIVE CENTS OF LOWER STATE
CORPORATE TAXES. IT REDUCES THE
STATE'S REVENUELEADING TO
BUDGET CUTS OUR TAXES BEING
RAISED ELSEWHERE ON THE HARD
LABOR WORKING FAMILIES
ADDITIONAL RESEARCH INDICATES
THAT STATES WITH STRICTER
CAMPAIGN FINANCE LAWS SPEND
MORE MONEY ON ENSURING THE
STRENGTH OF THEIR SOCIAL SAFETY
THAT. AND THIS SHOULD COME AS
NO SURPRISE AS CORPORATIONS
OFTEN OFTEN PRIORITIZE POLICIES
THAT INCREASE THE PROFIT
MARGINS RENDON THE POLICIES UP
WITH THE WELL BEING OF
EVERYONE. THE ISSUE WITH HAVING
OF CAMPAIGN FINANCE SYSTEM
ENTRENCHED IN THE IDEA THAT
MONEY IS SPEECH WHAT THE
CORPORATIONS ARE PEOPLE IS THAT
YOU ARE EFFECTIVELY. RELEGATING
LOW AND MIDDLE INCOME FOLKS TO
A SECONDARY CITIZEN STATUS
WE'RE BEING TOLD THEIR VOICE IS
LESS IMPORTANT OF THOSE WITH
LOTS OF MONEY THIS TYPE OF
GOVERNANCE IS COMMONLY REFERRED
TO AS PLUTOCRACY IN OTHER WORDS
A GOVERNMENT RUN BY THE RICH.
WHAT THE COVER FOR ELECTION
NEXT PROVIDES IS ONE STEP. IN
DIRECTION OF A LIMB BIG MONEY
FROM POLITICS I UNDERSTAND IT.
WILL NOT BE DISCOVERABLE AS WE
DESPERATELY NEED FEDERAL
ACTION. AND THANKFULLY CONGRESS
MEMBER DI PAUL FROM THE STATE
OF WASHINGTON HAS INTRODUCED
THE WE THE PEOPLE AMENDMENT.
THIS CONSERVE AMENDMENT WOULD
END CORPORATE PERSONHOOD
REVERSE CITIZENS UNITED AND
MAKE IT CLEAR THAT MONEY DOES
NOT EQUAL SPEECH. WE CAN'T SIT
IDLY BY IN SACRAMENTO AND WAIT
FOR CONGRESS TO ACT. WE MUST DO
EVERYTHING WITHIN OUR POWER TO
CURB CORPORATE INFLUENCE AND AB
TWENTY IS AN IMPORTANT STEP IN
ROUTING BIG MONEY OUT OF
POLITICS. I UNDERSTAND THERE
ARE MANY QUESTIONS AND I'M
WILLING TO WORK WITH EACH AND
EVERYONE OF YOU TO ADDRESS
THESE CONCERNS IS THIS IS
SOMETHING I FEEL VERY
PASSIONATELY ABOUT. ONE OF
THESE CONCERTS ONE OF THESE
QUESTIONS REYES AND ANALYSIS IS
THAT. IF A FORTY NINE HUNDRED
DOLLAR CONTRIBUTION FROM A
BUSINESS ENTITY IS SO
INFLUENTIAL WHY WENT. A SAME
CONTRIBUTION FOR CORPORATE
EXECUTIVES IS INFLUENTIAL UNTIL
THAT POINT. I AGREE. ALL WITH
THE MEANS SHOULD HAVE A LOUDER
VOICE IN A REPRESENTATIVE
DEMOCRACY AND THOSE WHO CAN'T
SPARE FORTY NINE HUNDRED
DOLLARS. HOWEVER IF AB TWENTY
WERE TO PASS A CORPORATE
EXECUTIVE WOULD BE ABLE TO
DONATE ONCE THROUGH THEIR
INDIVIDUAL. I'M SORRY WHAT'S
THEIR BUSINESS AND ANOTHER
DONATION AS AN INDIVIDUAL WHICH
BRINGS ME TO MY POINT ABOUT A
CONSTITUTION. THAT GUARANTEES
ARE OPERATIVE ALL
REPRESENTATIVE OPPOSITE THE
PEOPLE NOT COOPERATIVE THAT
GIVE THE RICH. WE ARE NOT MEANT
TO BE AN OLIGARCHY WE ARE BACK
TO BE DEMOCRACY FOR PEOPLE.
WITH THE DEEPENING INCOME
INEQUALITY AND WEALTHY PEOPLE
AFFORDED MORE POLITICAL
INFLUENCE. IS IMPERATIVE WE
COMMIT TO OUR VALUES THAT EACH.
AND EVERY PERSON HAS AN EQUAL
VOICE. AND THAT CORPORATIONS
ARE NOT PEOPLE. AND BEFORE I
AND BILL MOVE ON TO OUR
SPEAKERS I JUST WANTED OF. I
THANK ALL OUR WONDERFUL
SUPPORTERS AB TWENTY. LOOK
MOVE. MONEY OUT VOTERS IN OUR
WONDERFUL SPONSORED COURAGE
CALIFORNIA FREE SPEECH FOR THE
PEOPLE STAFF IS THE COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS THE CITY
OF BERKELEY. THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
DEMOCRATIC PARTY SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY DEMOCRATIC PARTY THE LA
COUNTY DEMOCRATIC PARTY SOLANO
COUNTY DARK VIçT. THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY DEMOCRATIC PARTY
CENSUS OF DEMOCRATIC PARTY
DEMOCRATIC PARTY OF CONTRA
COSTA. NAPA TECHNOCRATIC PARTY
OF ORANGE COUNTY UNITED
DEMOCRATS THE SAN GABRIEL
VALLEY AS ACTION. ALLIANCE FOR
BOYS AMEND THE COLOR AMERICAN
FAMILY VOICES CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENTAL JUSTICE ALLIANCE
CALIFORNIA WE GOT SURVATION
VOTERS. BECAUSE COMMUNITIES ARE
BURNED VIRANT COMMUNITY ACTION
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE COMMUNITY
ADVOCACY PROJECT THE HARVEY
MILK LGBT Q. DEMOCRATIC CLUB.
INDIVIDUAL EXTRA ON THE FAMILY.
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA CYCLING
ASSOCIATION PEACE AND FREEDOM
PARTY OF CALIFORNIA THE PLASTIC
POLLUTION COALITION PHYSICIANS
OF NATIONAL. OF YOUR POLICY
CALIFORNIA PROGRESSIVE ASIAN
NETWORK ACTION SAVE OUR SHORES
SEVENTH GENERATION ADVISORS THE
SIERRA CLUB. STUDENTS FOR
NATIONAL HEALTH CARE PROGRAM
SOUTH BAY CENTER I MOVEMENT
SILICON VALLEY SURFRIDER
FOUNDATION- COOK. THE FIVE
GYRES INSTITUTE CO ARE. THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY HUMBLE VALUE TO
UNDER FIFTY SILICON VALLEY AND
OVER TWO THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED
VIGILS AOUND SUPPORT. ALSO AND
I THANK ARE CALLED MICHAEL IT
IS ON THIS BILL SENATORS ALLEN
IN TORONTO ASSEMBLY MEMBERS OFF
KALRA KEVIN MCCARTY. AND I'M
EXTREMELY APPRECIATIVE. AND
HONORED OF EACH AND EVERY
SUPPORTER WHO JOIN ME IN THIS
FIGHT TO RID OF BIG CORPORATE
INFLUENCE IN CALIFORNIA- AND
WITH THAT. I'M PLEASED TO BE
JOINED BY TWO SUPPORTING
REDUCES RUN FINE WHO IS THE
LEGAL DIRECTOR FREE SPEECH FOR
PEOPLE. MICHELLE SUTTER WHOSE
DIRECTOR OF A CO FOUNDER OF
MOVIE. THANK YOU MISTER LEE
MOVING ON TO- A MISSILE SUTTER
IF MICHELLE SAID IT SHOULD BE
DONE TESTIFYING OF THE
TELEPHONE JUST A REMINDER YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES. OF TESTIMONY.
GOOD MORNING MARC BERMAN BERMAN
CAST OUR DAILY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. ON THE SOUTH DIRECT
OF MOBILE MONEY OUT FOLLOWERS.
UP THURSDAY A FOLLOW. NON NON
PART OR- DEDICATED TO REDUCING
THE INFLUENCE OF MONEY IN
POLITICS AND PROMOTING CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT WITH THE
ORGANIZATIONAL SPONSORS OF AB
TWENTY. ONE A CORPORATION
DONATES TO A CANDIDATE IT IS AN
INVESTMENT. IF DONATIONS TO
CANDIDATES DID NOT RETURN ON
THIS INVESTMENT CORPORATIONS
WOULD NOT MAKE THEM. EARLIER
THIS MONTH IN AN EMOTIONAL
FACEBOOK VIDEO THE PRESIDENT OF
THE MAINE SENATE INTRODUCED L.
B. FOURTEEN SEVENTEEN. WHICH
LIKE AB TWENTY PROHIBITS
CORPORATE DONATIONS TO
CANDIDATES BUT PERMITS UNION
DONATIONS. HE SAID AND I QUOTE.
I THOUGHT IF YOU DID THE RIGHT
THING PLAYED BY THE RULES THAT
GOVERNMENT WOULD BE THERE TO DO
THE RIGHT THING FOR YOU. AS
I'VE HAD MY EYES OPENED UP
CERTAINLY UNDERSTOOD BETTER
THAT FOR FAR TOO LONG. LARGE
CORPORATIONS HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
BY STATE GOVERNMENTS AND
REGULAR PEOPLE. JUST DON'T HAVE
THE MONEY TO BUY THEM BACK.
IT'S INCREDIBLY UPSETTING AND
IT'S REALLY HARD TO COMPETE
WHEN YOUR VOICE IS DROWNED OUT.
AND I BELIEVE WHOLEHEARTEDLY
THAT MAIN PEOPLE DESERVE A
GOVERNMENT THAT WORKS FIGHT AND
DELIVERS FOR REGULAR PEOPLE.
EVERYDAY PEOPLE WHO DON'T HAVE
THE BIG BANK ACCOUNTS TO PUSH
THEIR ISSUES NOT LARGE
CORPORATIONS AND SHAREHOLDERS
LIKE WE SEE TODAY. IT'S NOT
GOOD FOR THE GOVERNMENT AND
IT'S NOT GOOD FOR MAINE PEOPLE
ON CLERK. IT'S NOT GOOD FOR THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA EITHER. I
HOPE YOU WILL FIND AT SENATOR
TRIED JACKSON FINDS FOR MAN.
BUT NOW WITH THE TIME AND
DIRECT CORPORATE CONTRIBUTIONS.
TO CANDIDATES IN CALIFORNIA WE
ASK FOR YOUR I. THE TO ADVANCE
AB TWENTY OUT. OF THIS
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU. THE YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT UP WE HAVE FOR
WITH SPEECH PEOPLE ONCE AGAIN
EVERYBODY TWO MINUTES. THANK
YOU SHARE VICE CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
INVITING ME TO SPEAK I'M RUN
FINE ON- LEGAL DIRECTOR OF FREE
SPEECH FOR PEOPLE AND NATIONAL
NONPARTISAN AND NONPROFIT.
PUBLIC INTEREST ORGANIZATIONS
AND I WANT TO MAKE JUST A FEW
POINTS AND I WON'T REPEAT-
WITHIN MY WRITTEN TESTIMONY. OF
FIRST- JUST TO REASSURE THE LAW
IS THE BILL IS CONSTITUTIONAL
BOTH THE NINTH CIRCUIT AND THE
U. S. SUPREME COURT HAS UPHELD.
LIMITS OF THIS TYPE AND
FURTHERMORE IT IS ACTUALLY THE
STANDARD- AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
CONGRESS HAS BANNED
CONTRIBUTIONS OF THIS TYPE IN
NINETEEN OH SEVEN AND ABOUT
HALF THE STATE DO. BECAUSE FOR
PROFIT BUSINESSES PRESENT A
SPECIAL RISKS OF CORRUPTION
THAT ARE NOT THE TEAM THAT HAS.
CONTRIBUTIONS EVEN OF THE SAME
DOLLAR AMOUNT FROM I
INDIVIDUALS THAT CAN CONVERT
CORPORATE TREASURY FUNDS AREN'T
IN THE MARKET FOR SELLING GOODS
AND SERVICES INTO POLITICAL WAR
CHEST. AND ESPECIALLY LIKELY TO
HAVE VERY SPECIFIC NARROW
DESIRES FOR LEGISLATIVE OR
EXECUTIVE FAVORS. SPECIAL TAX
TREATMENT REGULATORY TREATMENT
LOCAL OR STATE APPROVAL THAT
THAT ROBS AND THAT'S NOT THE
CASE. HAS CONSISTENTLY WITH
INDIVIDUALS I UNDERSTAND
THERE'S SOME CONCERN THAT- THE
BILL COULD RESULT IN A BUSINESS
ENTITIES ITS SHIFTING FUNDING
TO OTHER CHANNELS. IT'S NOT A
FIXED POT WERE ALREADY THERE
ANY BUSINESS THAT HAS A SERIOUS
AMOUNT OF MONEY TO SPEND IS RT
NOT JUST MAXING OUT DIRECT
CONTRIBUTIONS BUT ALSO
CONTRIBUTING. AS MUCH TO
OUTSIDE GROUPS HAS IT FINDS
WORTH ECONOMIC WHILE BUT MORE
TO THE POINT I THINK- I DON'T
NEED TO TELL YOU BUT CERTAIN
THE COURTS HAVE REPEATEDLY
HELD. THAT FOR ANY GIVEN AMOUNT
OF MONEY AT BOTH- THE
CONTRIBUTORS AND THE
CANDIDATES- WOULD MUCH RATHER
HAVE A DIRECT CONTRIBUTION
WHICH THIS BILL PROHIBITS THEN
I CONTRIBUTION TO AN OUTSIDE
GROUP. AND FINAL POINT IS THAT
IN THE HALF OF THE STATE THAT
ALREADY DO THAT I DON'T THINK
THERE'S MANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC SAYING I THINK WE SHOULD
ALLOW. CORPORATIONS TO WRITE
CHECKS DIRECTLY TO CANDIDATES
THE WAY THE CAL. DOES RIGHT NOW
THANK YOU. YOU VERY MUCH- AND
WITH THAT WE WILL MOVE ON TO.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR IN OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY
AS OUR MANAGERS ALLOCATIONS FOR
THE COMMITTEE'S HEARING TODAY
THE PUBLIC WHAT FIFTEEN MINUTES
IN TOTAL TIME FOR ADDITIONAL
PUBLIC COMMENT. ALL ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES ARE LIMITED TO
PROVIDING THEIR NAME THE
ORGANIZATION THAT THEY
REPRESENT IF ANY AND THEIR
POSITION ON THE BILL. WILL
START HERE IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
ROOM WHO WISHES TO PROVIDE.
THEIR POSITION ON AB TWENTY.
SEEING NONE. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION TO PROVIDE A
POSITION ON AB TWENTY. SEEING
NONE WE WILL NOW OPEN THE PHONE
LINES FOR ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WHO WISH TO PROVIDE
THE POSITION ON AB TWENTY
MODERATOR DO YOU HAVE ANYBODY
ON THE LINE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK
IN EITHER SUPPORT OR IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY AND
JUST A LAST REMINDER THIS WILL
BE A FIFTEEN MINUTES OF PUBLIC
TESTIMONY PLEASE PROVIDE YOUR
NAME- ORGANIZATION IF ANY THAT
YOUR PRESENT AND YOUR POSITION
ON THE BILL. THANK YOU INDEED
WE DO HAVE- SOME. SOME LINED
UP. AND FOR THOSE OF YOU
WAITING IF YOU. HAD NOT HEARD
THE INSTRUCTIONS PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME AN EIGHTEEN
T. SPECIALS WILL PROVIDE YOUR-
BEARD LIE NUMBER. THAT WILL
CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER OUT WHEN
YOU ARE BEING. ASKED TO SPEAK
WILL FIRST GO TO LINE EIGHTY
FIVE. BY EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING EVERYONE
MY NAME IS. SORRY GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE TODD SCHNEIDER
INDIVISIBLE SAN FRANCISCO IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY.
THANK YOU. WE WILL GO NEXT TO
LINE FIFTY SEVEN GO AHEAD
PLEASE. GOOD MORNING MEMBERS TO
FIND HIM TO RUN OKAY YOUNG
YOUNG VULNERABLE GIRLS WILL
BOARD A PRESIDENT AND A HUGE A
BUNKER BECKLES. IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY THANK YOU
THANK YOU. WE'LL GO NEXT TO
LINE NINETY FOUR GO AHEAD. YES
MY NAME IS CAROLINE STAPLETON
I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
HOLLYWOOD CHAPTER OF THE
NATIONAL ORGANIZATION FOR WOMEN
ALSO THE CALIFORNIA PEACE
ALLIANCE AND ALSO THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY DEMOCRATIC PARTY
IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT OF AB.
TWENTY PINE FIFTY FIVE. MY NAME
IS DARLENE PATRICK AND I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
STATE STRONG COALITION AND
INDIVISIBLE STANISLAUS IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LINE
EIGHTY SEVEN. MORE ROMERO WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. BY. THIRTY
THREE- DR RON BURN BOND- FROM
LOS ANGELES REPRESENTING LOS
ANGELES COUNTY DEMOCRATIC PARTY
AS WELL AS INTERNATIONAL HEALTH
PROGRAM CALIFORNIA BOTH
ORGANIZATIONS AND- STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ENCOURAGE
YOU TO PASS IT OUT OF THE
COMMUNITY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LINE. EIGHTY THREE. THIS IS
CINDY ELSE MORE FROM THE SIERRA
COUNTY DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND-
RACHEL THIS CHURCH ONE ALLIANCE
FACTION IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL PLEASE PASS IT OUT OF
THE COMMITTEE. THANK YOU. BY
THE ONE ZERO TWO GO AHEAD. SH
YES HELLO THANK YOU ARE CLARA
ROBIN PRESIDENT OF THE WEST LOS
ANGELES DEMOCRATIC CLUB. AND WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY AND URGE YOU TO PLEASE
PATH OUT OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU. ONE SIXTY. MY NAME IS
SARAH THAT SHE SHOULD GET AND I
AM WITH THE SAN GABRIEL VALLEY
PROGRESSIVES AND ALSO THE THANK
YOU BOTH VALUE TENANTS ALLIANCE
AND A MEMBER OF THE PROGRESSIVE
DEMOCRATS OF AMERICA WE ARE
DEFINITELY IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY AND PLEASE PASS IT
THROUGH. THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU. LINE. SEVENTY SIX-
THAT'S YOU HOW DO I. YEAH JUST
TALKING CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
BEGAN OF PART. HI BUT NOT THE
WAR HI I AM A MEMBER OF EMERGE
CALIFORNIA CAUGHT THE TWENTY
ONE ALSO A MEMBER OF THE L.
THREE TO DEMOCRATIC CLUB
INDIVISIBLE EAST BAY AND THE
COMPLIANCE OFFICER FOR THE
CHERRY COKE SAN FRANCISCO BAY
CHAPTER- I'M ADVISORY BOARD
MEMBER THREE FIFTY BAY AREA AND
LOCAL LEADERS THE EASY ACCESS
FOR ALL COALITION. I AM
SPEAKING TODAY ON MY OWN BEHALF
BUT I AM SPEAKING IN VERY
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ONE THIRTY
EIGHT. GOOD MORNING SURE BERMAN
AND ARE ALL COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS AL WAY AROUND THE
PRESIDENT OF L. A. X. AREA
DEMOCRATIC CLUB IN AND OUT ON
BEHALF OF OUR ORGANIZATION I
WOULD LIKE TO SAY THAT WE ARE
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
ENERGY ALL TO PASS IT OUT OF
THIS COMMITTEE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. FIND. TWENTY ONE. THAT'S
YOU BY TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I'M SPEAKING CAN YOU HEAR
ME WE CAN WE CAN A LOT OF
PEOPLE HAVE NAME RECOGNITION OF
ANY IMPOSITION ON THE BILL YES.
YES I STARTED SPEAKING AND YOU
DIDN'T HEAR ME BEFORE OKAY MY
NAME IS MARCY LEVINE I'M IN LOS
ANGELES I'M CALLING JUST AS A
VERY CONCERNED INDIVIDUAL
ALTHOUGH I HAVE BEEN A MEMBER
OF- MOVIE IN THE PAST- AND I AM
CALLING. TO URGE YOU TO VOTE I
THE PAST AB TWENTY OUT OF
COMMITTEE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE REACH THE FIVE MINUTE MARK
OF PUBLIC TESTIMONY TEN MORE
MINUTES. PLEASE MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT PERSON. BY TWENTY NINE. HI
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS BY NAME IS
RAQUEL TARA ON BEHALF OF
COURAGE CALIFORNIA NEAR IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY.
THANK YOU. ONE FIFTY THREE. HI
MY NAME IS DON WILSON AND I AM
WITH THE SACRAMENTO AFFILIATE
OF MOVE TO AMEND AND WITH ME EL
DORADO PROGRESSIVES GROUP IN EL
DORADO COUNTY I STRONGLY URGE
AND I'D VOTE TO MOVE AB TWENTY
OUT OF COMMITTEE THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU. LINE EIGHTY
ONE. HELLO THIS IS MICHAEL
THREE THE LEGISLATIVE ACTION
MANY OF THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DEMOCRATIC PARTY REPRESENTS
MORE THAN FIFTY MILLION
DEMOCRATS IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
THE LAST ONE FOR SENATE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY SUPPORT AB
FINAL VOTE YESTERDAY. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. FIND TWO.
HI GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
LORRAINE KING I'M THE CHAIR OF
THE DEMOCRATIC WOMEN OF EL
DORADO COUNTY AND I'M CALLING
IN AND SUPPORTED STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY. THANK YOU. BY
NINETY SEVEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
KIRSTY MORAL I'M REPRESENTING
TOGETHER WE WILL INDIVISIBLE
FIRST GODDESS IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY THANK YOU THANK
YOU. ONE THIRTY TWO. BY THIRTY
TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING GOOD MORNING. OUR FROM
LONG BEACH NINETY OUT VOTERS
DAN AND STRONGLY SUPPORT
DEMOCRACY AND AB TWENTY THREES
YEAH THANK YOU VERY MUCH. BY.
NINETY TWO. GOOD MORNING- THIS
IS ANTONIO ROBINSON IN ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT THIRTY SEVEN AND MY
HUSBAND AND I STRONGLY BELIEVE
IN A. B. TWENTY AND ASK YOU TO
VOTE HI. THANK YOU. LINE. SIXTY
NINE. ONE SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. WILL MOVE ON TO LINE.
THIRTY SIX ONE SEVEN THREE
RECEIVED A NUMBER YET LARA WE
CAN ACTIVATE OR BIG GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS CITY WHATEVER
REPRESENTATION FREEDOM PARTY OF
CALIFORNIA- WERE IN SUPPORT OF.
AB TWENTY ALTHOUGH WE WOULD.
LIKE THE INDIRECT SUPPORT ALSO
REMOVED IN THE FUTURE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. LINE. FORTY ONE.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE NINE FORTY
ONE. NINE FORTY ONE IF YOU
WOULD QUEUE UP AGAIN WE CAN
PULL YOUR LINE OPEN AGAIN
PLEASE. NINE FORTY ONE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. GO AHEAD PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING CLEANER GONZALEZ
ON BEHALF OF HAMMOND CLIMATE
POLLUTION AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ONE VOTERS. WE'LL GO
NEXT JULY NINETY GO AHEAD
PLEASE. HI GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS NORA DOYLE MONEY OUT VOTERS
IN FROM STUDIO CITY AND I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LINE. TWENTY HI MY NAME IS
DENNIS DESCENDANTS FROM ASISTIR
AN ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FORTY
EIGHT ON ELECTED DELEGATES LOS
ANGELES COUNTY DEMOCRATIC PARTY
CENTRAL COMMITTEE AND I'M A
MEMBER OF THE UNITED DEMOCRATS
OF THE SINGLE VALLEY AS WELL AS
A MEMBER OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY
PROGRESSIVES I STRONGLY SUPPORT
AB TWENTY ENERGY TO PASS OUT OF
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU. BY.
NINETY SIX. HELLO MY NAME IS
JIM AND I'M NOT A LOS ANGELES
RESIDENT AND STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY. LINE. EIGHTY SIX.
PARDON ME LINE EIGHTY SIX IF
YOU WOULD REACH YOU BY PRESSING
ONE THEN ZERO WE CAN REOPEN
YOUR LINE. ALL RIGHT EIGHTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS
CHRISTOPHER YOUNG I'M IN
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT THIRTY SEVEN
AND THE CHAIRPERSON FOR
HONORABLY AUDI PROJECT OF
VENTURA COUNTY AND- HERE WITH
STRONG SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY
THANK YOU THANK YOU RIVERS THE
TEN MINUTE MARK FIVE MORE
MINUTES OF PUBLIC TESTIMONY.
NINE TWENTY SIX. LARRY MARAT
I'M WITH THE UNITED DEMOCRATS
OF THE SAN GABRIEL VALLEY AND-
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY AND FOR YOU TO PASS IT
OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. BY NINETY FIVE.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS MERRIAM
AFTER THAT I AM THE CHAIR OF
THE SOUTH BAY CHAPTER OF THE
NATIONAL ORGANIZATION STUDENTS
FOR NATIONAL HEALTH PROGRAM IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA OUR CHAPTER
ISN'T STRONG STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY YEARS YOU TO PASS.
OUT OF COMMITTEE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ON A QUICKLY TURN-
THE GAVEL OVER TO THE VICE
CHAIR TO RUN TO A DIFFERENT
COMMITTEE HEARING WILL BE RIGHT
BACK. RIGHT NEXT WEEK- LINE.
TWENTY SEVEN. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS RACHEL PACIFIC
COMMUNICATIONS DIRECTOR FOR THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY OF ORANGE
COUNTY OUR CENTRAL COMMITTEE
MEMBERS VOTED AND UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY AND WE ASK
FOR YOUR EYES OUT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT BAKER.
NINE SEVENTY THREE. A GOOD
MORNING JERRY VELASCO ON THE
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
DEMOCRATS THANK YOU WITHOUT AN
AWFUL LONG BEFORE MOST
COMPLEMENT- AROUND THE BORDER
OF EIGHTEEN FORTY NINE FORTY
EIGHT AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT-
AB TWENTY AND I HAVE TO PLEASE
CONSIDER PASSED. OUT OF
COMMITTEE THANK YOU MUCH THANK.
YOU SIR NEXT BIGGER. BY BYE.
SIXTY HELLO MY NAME IS
CAROLINGIAN PART I'M AN
EXECUTIVE BOARD MEMBER LATCH IN
NEED DEMOCRATIC STATE CENTRAL
COMMITTEE REPRESENTING ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT FIFTY ONE I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY AND
URGE YOU TO PASS OUT OF
COMMITTEE THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
WEEK PLEASE. BY. THIRTY FOUR.
HI MY NAME IS BARRY LEVINE I'M
WITH MOBY SANTA BARBARA AND I
INSTRUCT YOU AS FOR PROPOSITION
FIFTY NINE PASSED BY OVER 70%
OF CALIFORNIA WHETHER YOU
OPPOSE. OUR PLEASE JUST THAT
STATE YOUR ORDER EIGHTY ONE
EVEN MOVE IT FORWARD. THANK FOR
HER NEXT WEEK- PLEASE. LINE
EIGHTY. HI GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS JOE PETER ON THE DOURSON'S
AND RESOLUTIONS CHAIRPERSON
PERCENT OF BARBARA COUNTY
CENTRAL COMMITTEE AND A
DELEGATE TO THE STATE
CONVENTION AND I STRONGLY URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT EIGHTY TWENTY
THANK YOU SIR NEXT WEEK- PLEASE.
LINE. FIFTY ONE. DR WARRANT
STORAGE OF YOUR SANTA BARBARA
CALIFORNIA CO FOUNDER OF MONEY
OF MOTORS ENGINE A BARBER
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT THIRTY SEVEN
NOW WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THE WHOLE ORGANIZATION- OF
PASSING AB TWENTY. THANK YOU
SIR WE'RE GONNA TRY ND GET AS
MANY AS WE CAN AND SO WE GOT TO
KEEP IT TO THE NAME
ORGANIZATION SUPPORTER OPPOSE
WE GOT ABOUT A MINUTE LEFT. GO
AHEAD NINE NINE FORTY FOUR. NOT
STATE KATHERINE SPEAKING FOR
MYSELF AS A CONSTITUENT OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY HEY
NICOLE. NINE SIXTY NINE. BY
SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
S. MOVEON. WILL MOVE ON TO LINE
FIFTY ONE MOMENT WHILE WE OPEN
YOUR LINE. GO AHEAD PLEASE.
FIVE FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WE WILL MOVE ON TO LINE. FIFTY
TWO. CLEVELAND MAJOR PRO TO
PICK UP YOUR HANDSET. COME ON
COME ON EVERYBODY. NEXT BAKER
PLEASE BERMAN BONTA LINE FOR
LINE NINETY EIGHT. THE MORNING
CARE MEMBERS PATHOLOGY ON
BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS OF THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT SPEAKER PLEASE. FIVE ONE
NINE ONE HUNDRED. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE WE HAVE NO LINE ONE LINE
ONE HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SURE IT A MARK ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA BY MICHAEL AT THE
PLANT IN SUPPORT. OUR LAST
SPEAKER COMING UP. WELCOME TO A
LINE WHILE- THREE. HELLO MY
NAME IS ANTHONY RICARDO ARE I
AM A MEMBER OF THE UNITED
DEMOCRATS SINGULAR VALLEY ALSO
THE WHITTIER AREA DEMOCRATIC
CLUB. I STRONGLY SUPPORT AB
TWENTY AND I URGE YOU TO PLEASE
PASS THIS OUT OF POCKET BILL
OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE THANK YOU
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
ALL THE SPEAKERS WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU FOR TUNING IN AND
GIVING US YOUR OPINION FOR
THOSE THAT DID NOT GET TO DO
THAT YOU CAN STILL DO THAT
ONLINE JUST GO TO THE ASSEMBLY
WEBSITE. AND YOU CAN LEAVE AS
LONG OF A SUPPORTER OPPOSITION
AS YOU WISH AND THE COMMITTEE
WILL GET THAT SO AT THAT POINT
THAT IS THAT ALL I THINK THAT
BRINGS US BACK TO THE.
COMMITTEE NOW FOR A QUESTIONS.
YOUR A QUESTION COM. DID WE DO
I HAD ASKED IF THEY HAD DONE
OPPOSITION THERE'S NO PRIMARY
OPPOSITION IN THE IN THE QUEUE
ARE IN THE- ON THE NOTES SO
WE'RE GONNA GO TO. OPPOSITION
ONLINE SO IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION ONLINE MODERATOR.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU'RE
SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
MISTER CHAIRMAN WE HAVE THOSE
SPEAKING IN CASE IN OPPOSITION
ALL RIGHT VERY GOOD ON GREEN
BACK TO THE ROOM TO SEE IF
ANYBODY WANTS TO SPEAK ON IN
THE ROOM IT DOESN'T LOOK LIKE
IT ON THE REMOTE. NOBODY ON THE
REMOTE SO NOW WE WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE THE
COMMITTEE IS- WELCOME TO OFFER
COMMENTS. QUESTIONS. I'M NOT A
COMMITTED TO FOR THE QUESTION-
GO AHEAD MR THE CHAIR COULD USA
TNT HOW MANY CALLERS ARE STILL
LEFT ON THE SUPPORT CALL LINE
YEAH I CAN DO THAT- EIGHTEEN T.
HOW MANY WERE LEFT ON IT IS
ONCE WE MOVE BEYOND THAT WE
CLEARED OUT THAT QUEUE. SO WE
DO NOT HAVE ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS TIME IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO REOPEN THAT WE
COULD NOW THAT'S ALL RIGHT WE
GOT IT WE WANT TO KEEP OUR
TIMELINE BECAUSE WE STILL HAVE
MORE BILLS TO HEAR I DID HAVE
OPPOSITION. SINCE ANY
OPPOSITION ON THE- FRONT HERE
SO. SO ANYWAY WE'RE BRINGING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE NOW SO
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CONCERNS. JERRY WANTS TO I WILL
JUMP IN HERE NOBODY ELSE IS
GOING TO. SO ADEQUATE QUESTION
FOR YOUR YOUR BILL HERE- DOES
IT LIMIT THEIR CONTRIBUTIONS TO
POLITICAL PARTIES. THE BILL AS
IN PRINT TODAY DOES NOT LIMIT
POLITICAL PARTY CONTRIBUTIONS
AS POINTED OUT IN THE ANALYSIS
THOUGH I WOULD BE HAPPY TO DO
THAT IF THE COMMITTEE WHEN I
BECAUSE THE POLITICAL PARTIES
THEMSELVES ARE NOT LIMITED IN
HOW MUCH MONEY THEY CAN
CONTRIBUTE. TO A OR SPEND ON A
CAMPAñA INDIVIDUAL CANDIDATE.
SO ESSENTIALLY BY ELIMINATING
THIS TO THE INDIVIDUAL
CANDIDATES THEY JUST GIVE IT TO
THE POLITICAL PARTY THE
POLITICAL PARTY CAN SPEND A
MILLION DOLLARS ON ONE
CANDIDATE THAT THEY CHOOSE WALL
THE OTHER CANDIDATE IS LEFT IS.
THIS GREAT FOR WHATEVER YOU CAN
DO ON HIS OWN MONEY OR WHATEVER
THAT POLITICAL PARTY CAN SPEND
ON IT SO THAT CREATES THAT SAME
IMBALANCE THAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT- WITH THIS GRANT THAT'S
CORRECT AND IF- IF I MAY
MISTER. I WOULD BE HAPPY TO
AMEND THE BILL TO INCLUDE TO
MAKE IT VERY EXPLICIT BECAUSE
RIGHT NOW AS OUR FEDERAL
CONGRESSIONAL CANDIDATES IN
CAN'T TAKE DIRECT CORPORATE
CONTRIBUTIONS THE PARTY CAN
ALSO GO AHEAD. OF ME DIRECTLY
AND YOU KNOW THE REST OF IT
IT'S A- THERE IS AN ISSUE WITH
TRYING TO. LEVEL ARE YOU ARE
YOU YOU'RE TRYING TO LIKE LEVEL
THE PLAYING FIELD. BUT YOU HAVE
TO LEVEL IT FOR EVERYBODY AT
THE SAME TIME. OTHERWISE IT'S
NOT EVER GOING TO BE LEVEL. AND
THAT'S THE ISSUE I HAVE WITH
THESE ATTEMPTS I HAVE
ABSOLUTELY NO ISSUE WITH TRYING
TO GET ALL THAT OUT HERE I'D
LOVE IT. BUT IT IT YOU KNOW A
GREAT CREATES AN IMBALANCE NO
MATTER WHAT YOU DO UNLESS YOU
DO THE WHOLE THING. AND- SO
THIS IS ONLY A PIECE OF IT. AND
WE CAN'T DO ONE PIECE AT A TIME
BECAUSE OTHERWISE THAT THAT
CONTINUES. AND I MEAN YOU DAY
IMBALANCE CONTINUES- SO YOU
KNOW I AGREE WITH YOU- MONEY
NEED TO BE OUT. BUT NO MATTER
WHAT YOU DO IN IN THE POLITICAL
ARENA- WERE STILL THERE. YOU'RE
STILL GONNA HAVE SOME INFLUENCE
ON YOU AND- ADD TO THE EXTENT
THAT. THIS IS YOUR ONLY INCOME
THIS COULD BE. THAT COULD BE A
DETERMINING FACTOR IN WHETHER
YOU'RE SUPPORTING SOMETHING OR
NOT. SO YOU KNOW THAT'S IT
THOSE ARE THE KIND OF THINGS
THAT INFLUENCE YOU AND- THE
SUGGESTION BY A BY SOME WHO'VE
CALLED AND THAT. WERE FOR SALE
YOU KNOW I KNOW THAT THERE HAVE
BEEN PEOPLE FOR SALE BEFORE.
BUT I CAN ASSURE YOU THAT MOST
OF THE PEOPLE THAT I'VE DEALT
WITH. I'M HERE OR NOT. THEY'RE
HERE BECAUSE THEY HAVE A GOOD
HARD THEY WANT TO DO WHAT'S
GOOD FOR THEIR COMMUNITIES. AND
SO THAT TO ME DOESN'T PLAY INTO
IT AS MUCH AS- THIS IS THIS
IMBALANCE THAT WE ALWAYS HAVE
AND- YOU KNOW LIKE I SAID I
WOULD LOVE TO GET RID OF IT.
MISTER CHAIR I'LL HAND IT BACK
OVER TO YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER RESTER ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS QUESTIONS I
THINK THAT MR MAYES AND THE
MISTER LOW. YEAH. YOUR BROTHER
BEFORE BEING AMONGST THE PALM
THAT THERE IS. WHY THAT OTHER.
THE WHOLE SYSTEM- AND ACTUALLY
WOULD AGREE THAT THERE IS A
PROBLEM OUR SYSTEM AND MY
COLLEAGUES TO MY RIGHT- I JUST
TALK ABOUT SOME SOME OF THE- I
DON'T THINK ABOUT A LARGE WITH
WITH WITH PROBLEMATIC- IS NOT
THAT THERE POWERFUL INTEREST
GROUP. THAT ARE BECAUSE THERE
ARE- BOTH CORPORATE. AND LABOR-
OF WEALTHY INDIVIDUALS TO SPEND
ON BOTH THE LEFT AND THE RIGHT
TO SPEND. FIVE WHO'S EXCEPT
AMOUNTS OF MONEY ON CAMP- BUT
THAT'S NOT REALLY THE PROBLEM-
THE PROBLEM- FRANKLY- IS THE
ELECTED OFFICIALS- IT IS IT IS
AWESOME I'M REMINDED. OF THE
FORMER ASSEMBLY STE DEMOCRATIC
SPEAKER- JESS UNRUH. WHO SAID
IF YOU CAN'T TAKE THE MONEY
DRINK THE BOOZE EITHER FOOD ON
A PASS OVER THE NEXTONE- AND
VOTE AGAINST THEM A YOU DON'T-
YOU DON'T BELONG HERE- AND I
THINK AT THAT POINT IF YOU
DON'T BELONG HERE. IF THERE ARE
PEOPLE THAT ARE IN THIS
BUILDING- WHO- LIKE THE ONE OF
THE FOLKS WHO SAID THAT THEY-
THEY SUPPORTED THIS BILL SAID
THAT IF SOMEBODY GIVES YOU
CONTRIBUTION THAT IT'S AN
INVESTMENT AND THEY WANT TO
RETURN ON INVESTMENT IF THAT'S
THE CASE. THOSE FOLKS DON'T
BELONG HERE THEY SHOULD NOT
HAVE RUN AND IT SHOULD NOT
CONTINUE. TO BE HERE THAT'S NOT
THE WAY THAT OUR SYSTEM SYSTEM
WAS SET UP AND SO- YOU KNOW I
ALSO AGREE WITH- WITH MY WITH
MY COLLEAGUES FROM A FROM
MURRIETA THAT IF YOU'RE GOING
TO HAVE A BILL LIKE THIS- YOU
HAVE TO DO IT HAS TO GO. MUCH
FURTHER- AND YET EVEN WHEN YOU
GO THAT FAR IF IT'S IF IT'S NOT
JUST BUSINESSES IT'S IF YOU HAD
BUSINESSES AND LABOR ANY
ASSOCIATION ANY TWO GROUPS
COMING TOGETHER IF YOU SAY AN
S. CORPORATION FOR INSTANCE
CAN'T GIVE BETWEEN. TWO
PARTNERS BECAUSE THAT'S ALL AN
S. CORPORATION AS AS
CORPORATION AS A COULD BE- TWO
PARTNERS AND IF YOU SAY THEY
CAN'T GIVE BUT A HUSBAND A WIFE-CAN GIVE- BECAUSE THEY'RE
INDIVIDUALS IT REALLY IS THE
SAME THING IS STILL
INDIVIDUALS. AT THAT THAT THAT
ARE THAT ARE THAT ARE GIVING IT
SO IF YOU'RE GOING TO DO THAT
YOU HAVE TO GO VERY FAR BUT
THEN THE REALITY IS THERE ARE
STILL PEOPLE WHO DON'T HAVE
CORPORATIONS AND THERE'S A FEW
VERY VERY WEALTHY DONORS THAT
COMETO MIND THAT RIGHT VERY
VERY LARGE- INDIVIDUAL.
CONTRIBUTIONS ARE WE GONNA
LIMIT LIMIT THEIR SPEECH AS
WELL AND SO WELL I THINK YOUR
INTENT IS RIGHT I THINK THAT
THE BILL BEFORE US- IS FLAWED
IN IN IN IN MANY RESPECTS AGAIN
I KNOW YOUR HEART I KNOW WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO SOLVE. BUT I
THINK THE PROBLEM FRANKLY IS AT
THE HEART OF ALL OF US THAT ARE
HERE THAT HAS BEEN SOLID IN THE
PUBLIC HAS SEEN NOT BECAUSE
THERE HAVE BEEN SOME PEOPLE
LIKE JUST ON RECETTE BOTH SPOKE
SHOULD NOT HAVE BEEN HERE SO
THANK YOU. YOU MISTER MISS
MISTER LOW. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OF MISTER CHAIR- AND- THANK YOU
SIMILARLY FOR BRINGING THE
ISSUE. TO US HERE TODAY FIRST I
WANT TO COMMEND THE CHAIR OF
THIS COMMITTEE AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFF- AS YOU MAY
KNOW I SERVED AS A PREVIOUS
CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE. NASSAR
TO ANY OF A NUMBER OF YEARS ON
THIS COMMITTEE AND- WE HAVE
WORKED VERY HARD TO TRY TO
MAINTAIN THE INTEGRITY OF THE
ELECTORAL PROCESS. AS YOU WELL
KNOW ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE I WAS
THE AUTHOR OF A PREVIOUS
ITERATION OF THIS AND- THE
COMMITTEE PROVIDED THE
PRIVILEGE TO HAVE DIALOGUE. TO
ADDRESS THIS IN OPEN FORUM. AND
I THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT IS
THAT THAT IS THE JOB THAT WE
HAVE IS A DELIVER YOUR BODY TO
ALLOW FOR THAT CONVERSATION AND
DIALOGUE TO OCCUR. WHILE DOING
THE HARD WORK IN IRONING OUT
AND HAVING AND HEARING FROM
EACH OTHER ABOUT. WHAT WE WANT
TO SEE FROM OUR DEMOCRACY AND
ALLOWING FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TOSS AWAY AND SO. AGAIN
I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND THANK
THE CHAIR IN THIS COMMITTEE FOR
ALLOWING THIS PROCESS OVER A
NUMBER OF YEARS. TO HELP
FACILITATE THIS CONVERSATION- I
ALSO- I HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF A
DISAGREEMENT WITH SOME OF THE
STATEMENTS THAT YOU MADE. IN
YOUR OPENING COMMENTS AS BOTH
OF US HAIL FROM SILICON VALLEY.
I'M PART OF THE RHETORIC I
THINK IS DANGEROUS AND SAYING
THAT- CORPORATION IS BAD OR IN
PEOPLE ARE GOOD- BUT RATHER THE
LIFEBLOOD OF SILICON VALLEY OUR
COMMUNITY HAPPENS TO BE THAT.
OF CORPORATIONS WHEN WE LIKE
THAT OR NOT THAT IS THE REALITY
OF HIGH PAYING JOBS. AND MAKING
SURE THAT WE HAVE A TRAJECTORY
OF. HIGH PAYING JOBS AND
SUPPORTING PEOPLE OF COLOR
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
STEM. A WOULD BE APPLE NETFLIX
EBAY THAT IS WHAT SILICON
VALLEY IS MADE IN FACT WE'VE
SEEN THAT SILICON VALLEY HAS.
HELPED KEEP US OFF OF THE CLIFF
FINANCIAL CLIFF. WITH RESPECT
THE PANDEMIC SO I JUST. WANT TO
JUST SHARE THAT OBSERVATION
THAT I RICH CAUTION WHEN
TALKING ABOUT GOOD VERSUS BAD.
AND THAT OF. A JUST THE WEALTHY
SERVING IN GOVERNMENT I THINK
YOU BRING ME SOME TYPE OF
REFERENCE OF THAT. AS A
MILLENNIAL AS AGENCY YOU AND I
BOTH. ARE SERVING AS MEMBERS OF
THIS INSTITUTION IN A
RESPECTABLE INSTITUTION. IN
UNITED BOTH CANNOT LIVE IN THE
COMMUNITIES THAT WE REPRESENT.
BUT THAT'S NOT TO SAY THAT
THERE'S NO WORK TO BE DONE SO.
I JUST THINK THAT'S ALSO BEEN
POINT TO SAY SO JUST URGING
CAUTION WHEN TALKING ABOUT.
WHAT IS A GOOD OF VIABILITY
GOOD CONTRIBUTION. AND WHAT IS-
BAD. AND WOOD. I THINK
DISTINCTION HERE ALSO. DOING
THE KNOWLEDGE IN YOUR FROM OF A
CHAIR HEARD FROM SENATE MAY
ABOUT. THE INFLUENCE OF MONEY.
AND HOW DO WE GET THAT OUT INTO
A TOTALITY AND THAT'S WHY THE
WHOLE REFERENCE EARLIER THE
HARD WORK OF THIS COMMITTEE. TO
ADDRESSING THAT AND MOVING
FORWARD. BUT I HOPE THAT WE
DON'T PROVIDE A FALSE SENSE OF
HOPE. TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
AND TALKING ABOUT THAT THIS IS
THE PERFECT ITERATION. YOU OF
COURSE WERE KIND ENOUGH TO SAY
THAT YOU WERE WILLING TO TAKE
AMENDMENTS AND WORKING TO SEE
ON THESE ISSUES. YOU KNOW I HAD
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THIS. TO
WHICH I DO NOT BRING THIS
BEFORE THIS YEAR BECAUSE I WAS.
PARTICULARLY TAKEN BY THE
ARGUMENTS OF THIS COMMITTEE TO
LOOK AT A HOLISTIC APPROACH.
AND HOW WE DO THIS AND
MAINTAINING. THE INTEGRITY OF
OUR ELECTORAL PROCESS WHEN IT
COMES TO CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTIONS. I KNOW HAT THIS
CHAIR AND THIS COMMITTEE IS
EQUALLY COMMITTED. TO DOING SO-
I'M GONNA BE SUPPORTING THIS.
BILL BEFORE US TODAY WHILE IT
IS FLAWED BECAUSE I DO WANT TO
SEE THAT. CONVERSATION TO OCCUR
BUT- I DO ALSO WANT TO HEAR
ABOUT YOUR COMMITMENT. THOUGH
TO GIVE ME A GREATER SENSE OF-
UP OF APPROACH THAT YOU MIGHT
HAVE WITH RESPECT TO. HELPING
TO ENSURE THAT WE TACKLE THIS
AS A WHOLE IF WE BELIEVE
FUNDAMENTALLY THAT. THERE IS
UNDUE INFLUENCE OF. CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTIONS THEY SHOULD LOOK
AT A HOLISTIC APPROACH AND A
WIDE LEVEL. BUT I JUST- AGAIN
URGE CAUTION IN SAYING THAT
CORPORATIONS BUSINESSES ARE BAD
AND WE WANT TO. ELIMINATE THEM
IN TERMS OF THEIR THEIR
APPROACH BECAUSE- AS I'VE HEARD
BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE IT'S LIKE
A LEAKY BUCKET YOU PLUG ONE
HOLE IN THE- BAR COMES IN
DIFFERENT DIRECTION AS WE'VE
HEARD FROM. THE STAFF ANALYSIS
AS WELL TOO SO AGAIN LIKE A
COMMAND OF THE PROJECT THAT
YOU'RE MAKING BUT- HOPE TO GO
TO WORK WITH YOU. TO ENSURE
THAT AGAIN HAILING FROM SILICON
VALLEY THAT WE RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANCE. OF HARD WORKING
PEOPLE AND ALSO CORPORATIONS
WHILE ALSO DOING THE NECESSARY
WORK TO HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE
AS WELL TOO. SO I APPRECIATE
THE EFFORT AND WITH THAT I'LL
MAKE A MOTION TO SUPPORT THANK
YOU MR LOW. MAYES RUBIO YES
THANK YOU- THANK YOU MISTER LEE
AND YOU KNOW I AS WELL
APPRECIATE THAT THE
CONVERSATION AND- YOU KNOW WHEN
WE- ALSO TO MR. LOWEST POINT
WARM WHEN WE TALK ABOUT CREEK
RATIONS CORPORATE. ARE NOT
NECESSARILY. MULTI DOLLAR. I'VE
HAVE. PLAYED OF CORPORATION ARE
ONE PERSON CORPORATIONS THAT
MAKE YOU KNOW- ENOUGH TO
SURVIVE SUCH AS- YOU KNOW BLANK
LATELY MAKING A STATEMENT THAT
CORPORATIONS ARE ALL BAD OR-
ARE NECESSARILY ARE RICH. FOR
EXAMPLE IF THAT'S NOT THE CASE
AND- YOU KNOW AND AGAIN I
APPRECIATE- AND I THINK YOU AND
I HAVE HAD THIS CONVERSATION AS
WELL. I APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO BUT TO. MY
COLLEAGUES POINTS. YOU KNOW
WHERE DO YOU. YOU KNOW WHEN
YOU'RE PICKING THE WINNERS AND
LOSERS OF THIS THIS GAME AND
YOU KNOW A LOT OF. US WOULD NOT
BE HERE WOULD NOT. IF IT WERE
NOT FOR THE HELP OF. LOCAL
CORPORATIONS- FOR EXAMPLE BUT
ALSO. YOU KNOW NOT JUST. OF
MONEY IS NOT JUST GIVING
DIRECTLY TO CANDIDATES WE ALSO
HAVE INDEPENDENT EXPENDITURES
TO WHAT WE'RE DOING IS. WE'RE
LIMITING YOU KNOW THE-
ACCOUNTABILITY IF YOU WELL
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO DISCLOSE.
WHO WE RECEIVE- THE
CONTRIBUTIONS FARM. THE
INDEPENDENT EXPENDITURES. DON'T
HAVE THE SAME REQUIREMENTS.
THAT WE AS INDIVIDUALS HAVE TO
FILE. AND SO THAT ALSO. GIVES
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR FOLKS TO
HIDE MONEY. AND SPEND WHAT YOU
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND I CAN
ATTEST. FROM MY YOUTH MY
RAISING MY SIBLINGS REYES. THAT
THAT IT WAS. MULTI MILLION
DOLLAR- EXPENDITURES THAT WE
DIDN'T NECESSARILY- HAVE- AS
SOMEONE WERE WOULD HAPPEN BUT
ALL WE'RE GIVING THE POWER TO
THOSE ORGANIZATIONS TO BE ABLE
TO SPEND MORE MONEY. AND TAKING
IT AWAY FROM THE LOCAL FOLKS
THAT DO WANT TO SEE BETTER MEN
IN THEIR- ARE COMMUNITIES SO I
DO APPRECIATE THE EFFORT AND
AGAIN WE'VE HAD THIS
CONVERSATION BUT- AT THIS
MOMENT I CANNOT SUPPORT THE
BILL AND IS. UNLESS WE DO- AS
MY- COLLEAGUES TO THE WRITER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYES SAID THAT
WE DO A COMPREHENSIVE WITH
EVERYBODY IF WE'RE GOING TO-
HAVE EVERYBODY- YOU KNOW BE AT
THE SAME STANDARD AND EVERYBODY
HAS TO BE. INPUTTED INTO THE
INTO THE BILL AND ELIMINATE ALL
OF CONTRIBUTIONS AND I KNOW
THAT'S NOT THE BILL BEFORE US.
BY I CAN NOT SUPPORTED IN ITS
CURRENT STATE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND- A- MISSILE WE WILL
MAKE SURE YOU GET THE
OPPORTUNITY TO REPLY TO ANYBODY
YOU WANT TO ARE ALSO MOVE ON TO
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS. YEAH I
JUST WANT TO REPLY DO LOOK OF
WHAT THE THOUGHTFUL COMMENTS
FROM OUR COLLEAGUES AND YOU
KNOW I AM COMMITTED TO
WHOLESALE REFORM I THINK WE CAN
ALL AGREE THE CURRENT SYSTEM IS
VERY VERY MUCH BROKEN. AND YOU
KNOW WHY THE BILL IS TAILORED
THE WAY IT IS AT THE MOMENT IS
THAT WE ARE WORKING WITH IN A
VERY NARROW BAND OF
CONSTITUTIONALITY OR EVEN.
GRAYSON ACROSS SHOULD I WHICH
IS SAFE BECAUSE WE DO NOT HAVE
A FAVORABLE SUPREME COURT RIGHT
NOW IT'S THE SAME SUPREME COURT
THAT DELIVERED US. THIS IS
UNITED THAT SAID CORPORATIONS
ARE PEOPLE AND THAT HAVE
UNLEASHED A TIDAL WAVE OF
MONEY. OF BUT IT'S IMPORTANT TO
WORK ON THESE THINGS YOU KNOW I
DO COMMIT TO HOPEFULLY WORKING
WITH OUR COLLEAGUESAT THIS. IN
A IN A COMPREHENSIVE MANNER
RIGHT WE HAVE TO AND I JUST
COMMITTEE CONSTANTLY LOOK THAT
WE DISCLOSURE REQUIREMENTS. AND
HOPEFULLY THE FUTURE PUBLIC
FINANCING TO READ LEVEL PLAYING
CARDS THE PEOPLE HAVE THE SAME
SPENDING POWER- AND THEN MAKING
SURE WE'RE ALSO HAVING
LIMITATIONS RESULT LIMITATIONS
ACROSS THE BOARD FOR EVERY SORT
OF CANDID RIGHT. MY BILL- BUILD
UPON THE GREAT WORK FROM
ASSEMBLY BELOW- BECAUSE WE'RE
TRYING TO EXPAND THIS TO ALL.
CANDIDATES IN CALIFORNIA ARE
NOT INCLUDE RIGHT RATHER ITS
CITY COUNCIL MEMBERS KIND OF
DIVIDE THEIR STATE LEGISLATORS
THE GOVERNOR. WHO ALL HAVE
CERTAIN PLEASE SIX DIFFERENT
TYPES OF ROLES BUT THERE STILL
IS THE OPPORTUNITY FOR INFANTS
OR EVEN THE PERCEPTION THAT
ONCE WHICH CAN JUST BE A DANGER
START MOXIE- SO REALLY
COMMITTED TO CONSTANT WORKING
ON THESE ISSUES BUT- AGAIN YOU
KNOW WORKING WITHIN. THE
CONFINES OF THE CONCERT. AS IT
IS. RIGHT AND UNTIL I THINK WE
HAVE A CONCERTED EFFORT AND
SOMETIMES IT WILL TAKE A PIECE
OF PURCHASE WE HAVE TO HIT ONE
AT A TIME. TO GET THERE I THINK
WE- YEAH REFORMS LIKE AB TWENTY
WILL WILL BE UNNECESSARY BUT I
DO COMMITTEE KANSI WORKING WITH
YOU ALL BECAUSE I THINK.
IRONICALLY IT IS PERHAPS THE
ONE ISSUE EVERYWHERE EVERYONE
IS BUILDING HAS PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE WITH. SO WE ALL KNOW
HOW IMPORTANT IT IS TO GET A
RIGHT AND TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
RESTORE THE TRUST OF PEOPLE.
FAMOUSLY ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS FROM COLLEAGUES SEEING
NOT- YES MISTER BENNETT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND- AND IS YOUR
MIKE ON THE MEASURE THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF SURE
BERMAN AND- AS- MY COLLEAGUE OF
MR LOS AT- I'D LIKE TO
COMPLIMENT YOU FOR HAVING THIS
HEARING- SOME COMMITTEE CHAIRS-
WOULD JUST SIMPLY COULD NOT LET
THIS BILL COME UP FOR BECAUSE
IT IS CONTROVERSIAL AND- CAUSES
SOME ANGST FOR- FOR PEOPLE IN
TERMS OF THEIR POSITION. AND
CERTAINLY THAT ANGST IS THAT-
IF YOU DON'T SUPPORT THE BILL
IN ITS CURRENT FORM IF YOU
DECIDE NOT SECOND THE MOTION OR
WHATEVER IT MEANS YOU'RE IN
FAVOR OF BIG MONEY IN POLITICS
AND THAT'S THE YOU KNOW THAT'S
SORT OF THE SIMPLE UP APPROACH
AND SO TO AVOID THAT SOMETIMES
JURORS DON'T LET SOMETHING COME
FORWARD BUT TO YOUR CREDIT AND
TO THE CREDIT OF EVERYBODY
HERE- WE'RE HAVING THIS
CONVERSATION SO. I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO SHARE OUR- OUR
FEELINGS ABOUT THIS EARLY IN
THE IN THE PROCESS AND STUFF SO
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO SAY IN
PARTICULAR TO- I HEARD SOME
VERY- STRONG SUPPORTERS OF MINE
ON THE PHONE HERE- TODAY- WITH
THE BILL AND THAT SO I WANT TO
SAY HELLO TO THEM BECAUSE I-
PROPITIATE THEIR LONG TERM AND
STEADY SUPPORT FOR CAMPAIGN
FINANCE REFORM THAT THAT WE'VE
WORKED OUT BUT- BIG MONEY'S
CORRUPTING DEMOCRACY IN
AMERICA. IT'S JUST THAT SIMPLE
I MEAN YOU CAN'T YOU CAN'T
SEVEN PROBABLY ONE OF THE WORST
COUNTRIES IN THE WORLD OUTSIDE
OF COUNTRIES ARE JUST YOU KNOW
COMPLETELY- DICTATORIAL X.
SENTARA- IN TERMS OF THE
CORRUPTION AND WE DON'T HAVE AS
MANY SAFEGUARDS AS WE NEED AND
BECAUSE IT'S SUCH A SERIOUS
PROBLEM I'VE FOUGHT TO DECREASE
THE INFLUENCE OF BIG MONEY IN
POLITICS FOR THE LAST TWENTY
FIVE YEARS. I'M PROUD THAT- IN
MANY OF MY CAMPAIGNS HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO VOLUNTARILY LIMIT MY-
CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTIONS- I'VE
REFUSE CONTRIBUTIONS OF AND I
JUST THINK IF YOU JUST LOOK AT
MY TRACK RECORD EVERYWHERE YEAH
THE TRACK RECORD THAT I'M PROUD
OF IN TERMS OF NOT TAKING
CONTRIBUTIONS FROM PEOPLE THAT
WOULD HAVE UNDUE INFLUENCE AS A
RESULT OF THEIR CONTRIBUTIONS.
DEVELOPERS OF. ECCENTRIC CENTER
PEOPLE HAVE TO ANYBODY HAD A
CONTRACT WITH THE COUNTY- ALL
OF THE KIND OF. AND I'VE- AND
ONE A DAY. OF SIX. CAMP FINANCE
REFORM LAWS. INCLUDING WHAT IS
WIDELY LABELED AS TO TOUGHEST
CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTION LIMITS.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA FOR
COUNTY ELECTED OFFICIALS- AND-
I'VE LEARNED THAT. IN DOING ALL
OF THAT AND WRITING THOSE LAWS-
OF. THAT THERE ARE CONSTANT
BATTLES AND PUSH BACK AND
LEGAL- LOOPHOLES THAT PEOPLE
USE TO TRY TO GET AROUND THOSE
LAWS. SO I'VE LEARNED A REFORM
IN THIS FIELD IS VERY
CHALLENGING TO MAKE
PARTICULARLY GOOD REFORM THAT
THAT DISTRACTS PEOPLE'S FAIR
CENTER. AND I STRONGLY BELIEVE
THAT WHEN WE LAUNCH REFORM
EFFORT. BOTH EXACTLY WHAT WE DO
AND HOW WE DO IT. IS ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL TO OUR ABILITY IN THE
LONG RUN TO BE SUCCESSFUL IN
OUR EFFORTS. TO WIN CAMPAIGN
REFORM THAT DECREASES THE
INFLUENCE OF BIG MONEY IN
POLITICS. IF WE DON'T DO IT
PROPERLY IN OUR EFFORTS WE
ACTUALLY SET OURSELVES
BACKWARDS IN THE EFFORT- I
HIGHLIGHT MR LOS MOVE. DECISION
NOT TO RUN SOMETHING THIS YEAR
BECAUSE HE WANTED TO TRY TO
TAKE THE TIME TO HAVE TO GET
SOMETHING. SO FOR SOME OF THE
IMPLICATION OF NOT CHECKING
THIS MOTION TODAY AND I WON'T
BE SECOND. IMPLIES A SUPPORT OF
BIG MONEY IN POLITICS- NOTHING
COULD BE FURTHER FROM THE TRUTH
FOR ME- IT'S CERTAINLY NOT MY
POSITION OR MY LONG TERM GOALS
REMEMBER THIS ASSEMBLY. BUT
WHEN I MOVE FORWARD I WANT TO-
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT BOTH.
WHAT WE DO AND HOW WE DO IT IS
SOMETHING I FEEL IS
APPROPRIATE. THE WITH THAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
LISTENING TO MY COMMENTS. THANK
YOU. MISTER BENNETT AND- I'LL
MAKE SOME COMMENTS AND THEN-
MISTER WE GIVE YOU AN
OPPORTUNITY. TO CLOSE I
APPRECIATE THAT. THE COMMENTS
FOR MY CALL TODAY AND YOU KNOW
WHAT WOULD SECOND PRACTICALLY
EVERYTHING THAT MR BENNETT SAID
I SEE THAT MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE GENERALLY SHARED
DESIRE. FOR AN ELECTORAL
PROCESS THAT IS FAIR
TRANSPARENT AND ACCOUNTABLE.
AND I SHARE THE CONCERNS OF THE
AUTHOR. AND THE SUPPORTERS OF
THIS BILL ABOUT THE ROLE THAT
LARGE CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTIONS
AND EXPENDITURES. CAN AND
SOMETIMES DO PLAY IN OUR
ELECTIONS SO I WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR YOUR PASSION.
FOR THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE AND
YOUR INTEREST IN TRYING TO FIND
WAYS TO REDUCE THE INFLUENCE.
OF CAMPAIGN SPENDING IN
CALIFORNIA ELECTIONS THEN I
WANT TO ENCOURAGE YOU TO
CONTINUE YOUR WORK ON THIS
ISSUE. AND TO TRY TO FIND WAYS
TO STRENGTHEN OUR DEMOCRACY. IN
MY TIME IN THE ASSEMBLY I'VE
SUPPORTED EFFORTS TO ALLOW FOR
PUBLIC CAMPAIGN FINANCING
PROGRAMS AND EVEN AUTHORED
LEGISLATION. TO FACILITATE
THOSE PROGRAMS. IN AN EFFORT TO
ENCOURAGE MORE DIVERSE
PARTICIPATION IN THE POLITICAL
PROCESS AND TO GIVE CANDIDATES
AN ALTERNATIVE. TO RELYING ON
CAMPAIGN COUNTRY CONTRIBUTIONS
FROM PRIVATE DONORS. AND BASED
ON THE ORIGINAL VERSION OF THIS
BILL. I KNOW THAT YOU ALSO HAVE
AN INTEREST IN EXPLORING CAN'T
PUBLIC CAMPAIGN FINANCING
PROGRAMS. WELL I APPRECIATE
YOUR SENTIMENTS BEHIND THIS
BILL. THE ACTUAL BILL LANGUAGE.
WHICH IS THE PART THAT MATTERS.
FALLS WOEFULLY SHORT OF
ACCOMPLISHING THE GOALS YOU
WHEN YOU'RE SUPPORTERS CLAIM
THIS BILL ACCOMPLISHES. WHEN
YOU WHEN I FIRST DISCUSS YOUR
INTEREST IN TIS ISSUE IN MID
NOVEMBER. BEFORE YOU'RE EVEN
SWORN IN- I ENCOURAGE YOU TO
READ THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
FROM MR LOW'S BILL LAST
SESSION. IN THE CONCERNS THAT
WERE RAISED IN THAT ANALYSIS.
NOT ONLY DOES IT SEEM THAT YOU
DID NOT DO THIS. SINCE THIS
BILL HAS MANY OF THE SAME FLAWS
AS THE EARLIER BILLS. YOU ADD A
FINDINGS AND DECLARATIONS
SECTION THAT DECEIVES THE
PUBLIC. AND YOUR SUPPORTERS.
ASKED THE EFFECTIVENESS OF YOUR
PROPOSAL. YOU ARE BEMOANING THE
FACT THAT CORPORATIONS. SPEND
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ON BALLOT PROPOSITIONS IN
TWENTY TWENTY. IMPLYING THAT
YOUR BILL WILL ADDRESS THIS.
HOWEVER IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
BE VERY CLEAR WITH THE PUBLIC
THEY YOUR BILL THERE'S NOTHING.
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING TO RESTRICT
THE AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT
CORPORATIONS CAN SPEND ON
BALLOT PROPOSITIONS. YOU CLAIM
THAT THIS BILL WILL QUOTE BRING
US IN CONFORMITY WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IN TWENTY
TWO STATES ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
THIS IS ALSO VERY MISLEADING.
AS THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
CLEARLY STATES FEDERAL LAW AND
THE LAW AND THE VAST MAJORITY
OF THOSE TWENTY TWO STATES IS
SIGNIFICANTLY DIFFERENT THAN
WHAT YOU'RE PROPOSING. THE TERM
YOU USE BUSINESS ENTITY. IS
MATERIALLY DIFFERENT THAN THE
DEFINITION F CORPORATION THAT
IS USED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND THE OTHER STATES
AND YOU ALLUDED TO.
CONSTITUTIONAL CONCERNS BUT BUT
CLEARLY IF THOSE DEFINITIONS
ARE USED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND THE OTHER STATES
THOSE ARE CONSTITUTIONALLY
SOUND. USING THE TERM BUSINESS
ENTITY IS YOUR BILL DOES
CREATES LOOPHOLES SO BIG YOU
COULD DRIVE AN ARMORED TRUCK
THROUGH THEM. THERE ARE ALSO
LEGITIMATE CONCERNS EXPRESSED
BY CAMPAIGN FINANCE AND
ELECTION LAW EXPERTS LIKE
JESSICA LEVINSON FROM THE GET
THE OIL LOYOLA LAW SCHOOL. THAT
AB TWENTY WON'T ACTUALLY REDUCE
THE AMOUNT OF CORPORATE
SPENDING AND POLITICS. WE'LL
JUST SHIP THAT SPENDING TO LESS
TRANSPARENT AND LESS
ACCOUNTABLE ROUTES LIKE
<c.red>NDEPENDENT EXPENDITURES. THAT</c>
IS NOT PROGRESS. WHEN WE SPOKE
ABOUT A MONTH AGO I ENCOURAGE
YOU TO AMEND THIS INTO A STUDY
BILL. AND TO ENGAGE EXPERTS IN
THIS FIELD TO TAKE A DEEP DIVE
ON THE INFLUENCE OF MONEY IN
POLITICS AS WELL AS THE ISSUE.
OF PUBLIC CAMPAIGN FINANCING.
YOU POLITELY DECLINE MY
SUGGESTION WHICH IS ABSOLUTELY
YOUR PREROGATIVE. AND REQUESTED
THAT THE BILL RECEIVED A
HEARING WHICH IT HAS. IF THE
BILL DOES NOT MAKE IT OUT OF
COMMITTEE TODAY I WOULD
ENCOURAGE YOU TO REVISIT MY
SUGGESTION. TO ENGAGE WITH
EXPERTS INCLUDING SOME ON THIS
COMMITTEE. AND TRULY TAKE A
DEEP DIVE INTO THIS IMPORTANT.
BUT COMPLICATED POLICY. THANK
YOU MISSILE MISSILE A I'D GIVE
YOU AN OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE. I
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND AS
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM. VENTURA
COUNTY SANTA BARBARA COUNTY. AS
A LISTED TO- YEAH I WANNA THANK
YOU OR GIVING OPPORTUNE TO
HAVE THIS BILL HEARD EVEN
THOUGH IT IS CONTROVERSIAL
ISSUE AND AGAIN AND I'M
COMFORTABLE ISSUE- AS THE
ANALYSIS THAT NOTED. IN A
TWENTY TWENTY CYCLE. ONE
HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS ARE SPENT TO JUST TWO
CANDIDATES SEEKING OFFICE AN
EXACT AMOUNT OF. OUT OF THAT
AMOUNT OVER TWENTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS IS DIRECTLY FOR
CONTRIBUTIONS WHICH WE SEEK TO
ELIMINATE. AND THAT AVERAGES
OUT ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO BE OVER
TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER MONTH. NOW THIS
OBJECTIVELY IN THE BRAND SCOPE
OF MONEY IS RELATIVELY SMALL
BECAUSE THEY ARE OUR OPTIONS
HAVE BECOME SO BLOATED. IS A
LOT OF MONEY TO EVERYDAY
CALIFORNIANS CALIFORNIANS WHO
ARE STILL MAKING MINIMUM WAGE
WERE STILL STRUGGLING TO THE
PANDEMIC. AND YET THERE'S
MILLION TO MILLION DOLLARS
FLOWING EVEN DURING THE
PANDEMIC ELECTION CYCLE- I
THINK AB TWENTY IS AN IMPORTANT
STEP IN A PETROL SEPTA MAKING
FOR THE REFORM THAT WE ALL WANT
TO DO. OF COURSE IT'S NOT
PERFECT AND AGAIN HAVING
KNOWLEDGE IS NOT A SILVER
BULLET BUT IT'S SOMETHING I
COMMITTED TO KEEP WORKING ON IF
IT'S OR CUT OFF COMMITTEE.
WHERE TO KEEP MAKING IT-
IMPROVEMENTS TO IT AND MAKING
SURE THAT IS UNIFORM. ALSO THAT
WE ARE TACKLING THE ISSUES THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT- AND JUST
QUICKLY YOU KNOW. RUN FINE WHO
TALKED ON OUR CALL WAS
WITNESSED. HE AND HE MADE A
REALLY GOOD POINT IS THAT THIS
CORPORATE MONEY IS NOT FIX POT.
RIGHT NOW THERE ARE SEVERAL
AVENUES OF INFLUENCE RIGHT I
EAT INDEPENDENT EXPENDITURES
PACKS AND OUR COUNTRY'S BEING
SOME OF THEM JUST BECAUSE
RECALLS DOOR ONE OF THEM DOES
NOT NET IN A- UP A EXACT AMOUNT
GOING TO THE OTHERS. THESE ARE
ALL AVENUES THEY'RE CURRENTLY
USING TO INFLUENCE OUR
DEMOCRACY AND WE SHOULD BE
DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN WITHIN
OUR POWER TO LIMITING IT. I
REALLY HOPE TO GET YOUR SUPPORT
TODAY AND THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
HAVING HEARING. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR. SO IT LOOKS LIKE THAT
MOTION FAILS FOR LACK OF A
SECOND. BUT THE BILL REMAINS IN
IN THE COMMITTEE- AND BEFORE TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH HIM ON
THIS ISSUE. THANK YOU THINK
INITIALLY. THAT'S HONORABLY.
MOVING ON TO THE NEXT BILL ON
THE AGENDA. MR MCCARTY. EIGHTY
SEVEN FIFTY NINE. WE HAVE A
MOTION. SECOND AND THE SECOND
OKAY THANK YOU FOR THE MOTION
THE SECOND THAT THIS BILL IS
ABOUT INCREASING OUR DEMOCRACY
FOR COUNTY ELECTIONS RELATED TO
NOT ONLY D. A. AND SHERIFF BUT
ASSESSOR ANOTHER LOCAL COUNTY
RACES THIS ISSUE CAME OUT HERE
IN MY LOCAL COMMUNITY HERE IN
SACRAMENTO. AND WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT THE- THE SIGNIFICANT-
SPECIFICALLY THE DA AND SHERIFF
FOR A RACES THERE HELD DURING
GUBERNATORIAL YEARS NOT DURING
HAVE AS MUCH TURNED OUT- IN
INCOME IS LIKE SACRAMENTO AND
LOS ANGELES THE TURNOUT IS-
MANY TIMES- DOUBLE IN A
PRESIDENTIAL YEAR SO MORE
PEOPLE PARTICIPATING IN
IMPORTANT COUNTY WIDE
ELECTIONS. I CERTAINLY THINK IS
A POSITIVE- LOCAL GOVERNMENT
IMPACTS OUR DAILY LIVES IMPACTS
OUR COMMUNITIES AND THAT THIS
IS A MEASURE THAT WOULD ALLOW A
GREATER NUMBER OF PEOPLE
ESPECIALLY LOWER INCOME
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR ENGAGE ON
SOME OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
OFFICES IN COUNTY GOVERNMENT-
WITH ME TODAY ARE THE LAKE
WOMAN VOTERS AND INITIATE
JUSTICE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU
ABOUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
MCCARTY AND AS YOU SAID WE'VE
GOT- TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT- INTERVIEWS FISHER AND
TANYA ON JELLY VARGAS- YEAH
BELIEVE IT TESTIFYING BY
TELEPHONE A REMINDER YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES- PER WITNESS. FOR
TESTIMONY PLEASE PROCEED. GOOD
MORNING ARE I SHOULD SAY GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
MY NAME IS INTERNET STRUCTURE I
AM A PUBLIC POLICY COORDINATOR
WITH THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS
OF CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME HERE TODAY TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN FIVE
NINE. AT LEAST BELIEVE THAT
DEMOCRACY INSTRUMENTS WINNER
PRESENTED AT THE TWO THOUSAND
AND ELECTIONS OF THE HIGH
STREET AND BROADEST DIVERSITY
AND VOTER TURNOUT. IT'S A WELL
ESTABLISHED FACT THAT
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION THE TRACK
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE VOTERS THAN
THE TERM COMBINATORIAL
ELECTIONS. IN SOUTH ACT THAT
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTIONS
ATTRACTED. MORE REPRESENTATIVE
BODY OF VOTERS. ACCORDING TO
THE FRANK DEMOCRACY WHEN
COMPARING THE NOVEMBER TWENTY
EIGHTEEN GUBERNATORIAL ELECTION
IN NOVEMBER TWENTY TWENTY
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION. TURNOUT
OF ELIGIBLE ASIAN AMERICAN
VOTERS INCREASED BY FIFTEEN
PERCENT. AND TURNOUT OF
ELIGIBLE LATINO VOTERS
INCREASED EIGHTEEN PERCENT. A
SIMILAR TREND CAN BE SEEN YOU
VOTER TURNOUT WHICH INCREASED
21% OF THE PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION. THE DATA HERE IT'S
CLEAR CANDIDATES ELECTED DURING
MID TERM ELECTIONS ARE SELECTED
BY SMALLER LESS REPRESENTATIVE
PROPORTION OF ELIGIBLE VOTERS.
AMERICAN OF ELECTED DURING
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION YEARS. AB
SEVEN FIVE NINE LONG COURAGE
MARKETERS TO PARTICIPATING
COUNTY ELECTIONS ALLOW MORE
UNDERREPRESENTED VOTERS TO
PARTICIPATE MAKING CRUCIAL
LOCAL DECISION. WILL THEREFORE
INCREASE ILLEGITIMACY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY OF LOCAL ELECTED
OFFICES. ENSURING THAT A LARGER
AND MORE CRITICAL ABOUT OUR
SKIN COLOR THE CANDIDATES
REFLECT THEIR VALUES IS
CRITICAL TO MAKING DEMOCRACY
WORK. FOR THESE REASONS THE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA'S IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB SEVEN FIVE NINE. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
WE'LL MOVE ON TO TANYA FROM
INITIATE JUSTICE. GOOD
AFTERNOON HEARING MEMBERS MY
NAME IS TIENE OF OUR GUESTS AND
THE FOUNDER AND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF INITIATE CHESTER-
INITIATE JUSTICE. INITIATIVE TO
THE VIKING AND NOTHING
CORPORATION BY ACTIVATING THE
POLITICAL POWER OF THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE DIRECTLY IMPACTED BY
INCARCERATION INITIATE JUSTICE
ISN'T STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
SEVEN FIFTY NINE BECAUSE WE
BELIEVE THAT IT WILL INCREASE
POLITICAL EQUALITY AND
ENCOURAGE INCREASE VOTER
PARTICIPATION FOR IMPORTANT
COUNTY ELECTED POSITIONS. SAY
THE VOTER TURNOUT OVER THE LAST
FORTY YEARS REVEAL THAT VOTER
PARTICIPATION AT HIGHER THE
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION- THAN IT
IS FOR GUBERNATORIAL ELECTION
SPECIFICALLY THE PUBLIC POLICY
INSTITUTE OF CALIFORNIA FOUND
THAT IF ELECTIONS WERE MOVED TO
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION YEAR THE
STATE COULD BE AN OVERALL 31%
INCREASE IN VOTER TURNOUT.
COUNTY OFFICIAL COUNTY OFFICES
INCLUDE ROLES SUCH AS COUNTY
SHERIFF'S AND DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S GOVERNMENT THE
IMPACT THE LIVELIHOODS AND
FREEDOM OF THE MEMBERS OF THEIR
COMMUNITIES THEREFORE IT IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO HAVE AS
MANY PEOPLE AS POSSIBLE
PARTICIPATING COUNTY ELECTIONS
BECAUSE THIS ENSURE THAT THOSE
OFFICES ARE TRULY REPRESENTED
HALF OF THE YEAR HAVE THEIR
LAUGHTER AT. BLACKLEY MOVING TO
RED HOOK MOVING ELECTIONS FOR
COUNTY WIDE OFFICE FOR MID TERM
ELECTION CYCLE TO PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION CYCLE MAY RESULT IN A
MORE BALANCED NUMBER. OF
CONTACTS ON THE BALLOT EACH.
GLOBAL ACTION BY. FISCAL THE
PROCESS THERE CREE ANOTHER PATH
TO ENCOURAGE AND BURGER. THIRTY
THREE THE FINISHING SECOND
BUSINESS FONG RECORDED AB SO
FIFTEEN AND CORRECTIVE YOU'RE
AYE ABOUT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AND SEEING AND KNOW
WHAT THE FROM WITNESSES IN
OFFICE AND FINDING WAY IN THE-
THAT'S NOT RIGHT. I WE'RE GONNA
MOVE TO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR IN OPPOSITION OF AB
SEVEN FIFTY NINE AS A REMINDER
TO ACCOMMODATIONS FOR THE
COMMITTEE'S HEARING TODAY THE
PUBLIC WHILE FIFTEEN MINUTES IN
TOTAL TIME. FOR ADDITIONAL
PUBLIC COMMENT ALL ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES ARE LIMITED TO
PROVIDING YOUR NAME THE
ORGANIZATION THAT YOU REPRESENT
IF ANY AND YOUR POSITION ON THE
BILL WILL START HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM IS OR ANYONE IN
THE ROOM WHICH IS PROVIDE THE
POSITION ON AB SEVEN FIFTY NINE
IS SEEING NINE. WILL KICK IT
OVER TO WITNESS- TO REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION ANYBODY OVER
THERE SAYING NONE WE WILL NOW
OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WHO WISH
TO PROVIDE THEIR POSITION ON
EIGHTY SEVEN FIFTY NINE. AGAIN
A REMINDER I FIFTEEN MINUTES
TOTAL PLEASE SAY YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION OF ANY AND
POSITION ON THE BILL OPERATOR
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES ON THE
TELEPHONE LINES WHO WISH TO.
TESTIFY YES WE DO HAVE SEVERAL
IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME WILL
FIRST GO TO LINE THIRTY ONE GO
AHEAD PLEASE. I HAVEN'T DURING
NON EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
ORGANIZED SACRAMENTO WE ARE
PROUD SPONSORS OF THE BILL AND
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU WEINSTEIN
LINE. SEVENTY ONE. HELLO GOOD
AFTERNOON MICHELLE TERRIFIED
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE CLEAR
DEMOCRATIC SACRAMENTO COUNTY
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY OF
SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND THE
REGION THREE OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH BY
LINE FORTY FOUR. IF CATHARINE
CO PRESIDENT OF CALIFORNIANS
FOR ELECTORAL REFORM WE'VE
TAKEN A POSITION OF OPPOSE
UNLESS SB SEVEN FIFTY NINE IS
AMENDED TO REMOVE THE LOCK IN
OF TWO ROUND RUN OFF SO THAT
CHARTER COUNTIES TO THE TOP
RANKED CHOICE VOTING IF THEY SO
DESIRE WE REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION
WITH SUCH AN AMENDMENT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU BY. EIGHTY FIVE.
RIGHT EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
EUROPE. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYONE TALKS LATER
CALIFORNIA THAT INDIVIDUAL
TEMPERATURE SCOPE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY SEVEN FIVE
NINE AND I URGE YOU TO PASS IT
OUT OF COMMITTEE THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. BY THE ONE
TWENTY FOUR. MISTER KAREN
MEMBER SHALL BE AS THE LEAST
SHOT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
AND STOCK THE PART THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. LINE ONE TWENTY
THREE. ONE MOMENT YEAH OKAY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN NOW. THIRTY
MORAL REPRESENTING TOGETHER WE
WILL INDIVISIBLE THIS GUIDANCE
IN STRONG SUPPORT AT EIGHTY
SEVEN FIVE NINE THANK YOU. LINE.
ONE TWENTY FIVE. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN BRUCE CORRIE CELLS
L. ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION- FOR
THE REASONS NOTED IN THE
ANALYSIS RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED
TO THE BILL THANK YOU. THANKS
VERY MUCH. BY THE. ONE TWENTY
SEVEN. HELLO ROBERT LONGER WITH
THE COMMUNICATIONS WORKERS OF
AMERICA AND STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU. LINE ONE
TWENTY SIX. NYLA ALAMEIN WITH
BACK RENTAL AREA CONGREGATIONS
TOGETHER AND IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIRMAN WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE INTO IT THIS
TIME. ACCORDINGLY WE DO HAVE
ONE MORE LINE PLEASE WHAT WHAT
LIGHT SIXTY FIVE. HELLO THIS IS
CAROLINE GM PARK EXECUTIVE
BOARD MEMBER ELECTED IN A
DEMOCRATIC STATE CENTRAL
COMMITTEE REPRESENTING ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT FIFTY ONE. I AM AND
CONCORD AB SEVEN FIVE NINE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE IN TWO AT THIS TIME
YOU MAY PROCEED APPRECIATE THAT
BRING BACK THE CALLS FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS WITH A
MOTION AND A SECOND ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. SEEING
NONE MR MCCARTY WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE HI I APPRECIATE THE DEEP
DISCUSSION AMONG THE COLLEAGUES
HERE TODAY THE TIME THAT I DID-
I DID WANT TO- I KNOW YOU'RE
JUST FATIGUE FROM LONG WEEK
SENT AND A BIG PRIOR BILL- BUT
BUT I DID WANT TO NOTE IN JUST
RESPONDED TO THE OPPOSITION.
THAT- YOU KNOW WE RESEARCH
SHOWS THAT- IN PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTIONS EVEN THOUGH THERE IS
A DROP OFF AFFECT YOU STILL
HAVE WAY MORE PEOPLE
PARTICIPATING. AND IN THE
GUBERNATORIAL ELECTIONS AS WELL
AS ANALYSIS NOTES. THEY MADE A
STATEWIDE OFFICES WHICH
ACTUALLY MAKE THAT BALLOT
LONGER SO- THE OPPOSITION THAT
STATUS QUO DOESN'T LIKE CHANGE
BUT I CERTAINLY THINK THAT MORE
PEOPLE VOTING IN THESE RACES-
MORE REFLECTIVE- COLLECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA IS A POSITIVE THING.
PEOPLE DON'T WANT CHANGE ONE OF
A WIDER. I'M MORE CONSERVATIVE
ELECTORATE TO KEEP THE STATUS
QUO AS IT IS I THINK THAT IN
THIS ERA TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
THAT WE'RE LOOKING TO DO THINGS
DIFFERENTLY AND HAVING MORE
PEOPLE PARTICIPATE IN THAT BUT
I WAS LIKE THIS IS GOOD FOR
DEMOCRACY. AFTER ARRIVAL
THINKING. THANK YOU MR MCCARTY-
AND AS THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
POINTS OUT THE LEGISLATURE HAS
TAKEN A NUMBER OF STEPS IN
RECENT YEARS TO IMPROVE
PARTICIPATION IN ELECTIONS FOR
LOCAL OFFICE. THIS BILL
CONTINUES THAT TREND AND WILL
HELP ENSURE THAT ELECTED COUNTY
OFFICIALS ARE CHOSEN BY AN
ELECTORATE. THAT MORE
ACCURATELY REFLECTS THE
DEMOGRAPHICS OF COUNTY
RESIDENTS AND FOR THAT REASON
I'M RECOMMENDING. SUPPORT FOR
YOUR BILL WITH THAT MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE VOTE.
THE MOTION TO PASS AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN HI BERMAN
I SAY OUR TELCO SAY ARTURO NO.
SENATE HI. I HELLO. HELLO I
MAYES. AS IS NOT KNOWN MULLIN
BLANCA RUBIO BLANCA RUBIO I.
FORTY ONE FOR ONE FORTY ONE THE
BILL HAS ENOUGH VOTES TO FORTY
ONE WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS AND WITH THAT
WE'LL MOVE ON TO AGENDA ITEM
NUMBER THREE A. B. FIFTEEN
FORTY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CHAO. READY WHEN YOU ARE SIR
THANK YOU GOT A MOTION AND A
SECOND THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
MR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND
THANK YOU FOR THE MOTION
FIFTEEN AB FIFTEEN FORTY SIX
WOULD PERMIT THE CITY OF
ALHAMBRA NDL HAMMER UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT TO CONDUCT A
SPECIAL ELECTION. IN ORDER TO
PROCEED WITH ITS A TRANSITION
FROM AT LARGE TO BY TRUSTEE
AREA ELECTIONS FOR MEMBERS OF
THE BOARD OF EDUCATION IN ORDER
TO COMPLY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
VOTING RIGHTS ACT OF ABOUT TWO
THOUSAND AND ONE. NO DURING THE
IN NOVEMBER THIRD TWENTY TWENTY
GENERAL ELECTION MISSION G.
WHICH APPEARED ON THE BALLOT
SOUGHT TO REMOVE FROM THE CITY
CHARTER ALL REFERENCES TO THE-
HAVE A UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
HOWEVER MEASURE G. ONLY APPEAR
ON THE BALLOTS OF THE VOTERS
RESIDING IN THE CITY OF
ALHAMBRA AND NOT ON THE BALLOT
SO VOTERS IN ALHAMBRA UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT WHO RESIDE
OUTSIDE OF THE CITY BOUNDARIES.
UNDER EXISTING LAW CHARTER
AMENDMENT FOR CITY MUST BE
SUBMITTED TO VOTERS AT AND
ESTABLISH A STATEWIDE GENERAL
ELECTION ARE CONSEQUENTLY- THE
CITY OF ALL HAMBRE AND THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT A BOTH A
PROHIBITED FROM CONDUCTING A
SPECIAL ELECTION TO AMEND THE
CHARTER PRIOR TO THE NEXT
STATEWIDE ELECTION ON NOVEMBER
EIGHTH A TWENTY TWENTY TWO. SO
THEREFORE WE NEED TO CREATE A
SPECIAL EXCEPTION INTHE
GOVERNMENT CODE TO PERMIT THE
CITY OF ALL HAMBRE IN THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT TO CONDUCT A
SPECIAL ELECTION BEFORE THE
NEXT STATEWIDE GENERAL ELECTION
TO ACHIEVE THIS I HAVE ADDED
EMERGENCY COST HOW TO THIS VERY
IMPORTANT DISTRICT SO WITH THAT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AB THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND IT LOOKS LIKE
WE HAVE TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT. THE DEAN LOGAN FROM
L. A. COUNTY REGISTER VOTERS
WHO IS THE L. A. COUNTY
REGISTER VOTERS AND JONATHAN
SALT FROM THE ALHAMBRA UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT- TESTIFYING. BY
TELEPHONE READY WHEN YOU'RE
OLDER. I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
GET OUT- MY IS DEAN LOW. AND
I'M THE RED RECORDER CLERK A
ANGELES COUNTY. AND I
TESTIFYING TODAY ON BEHALF OF
OUR BOARD OF SUPERVISORS. WE
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF AB FIFTEEN FORTY
SIX AND WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHAO FOR
OFFERING. AS WELL AS THE
ALHAMBRA UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN THE CITY OF
ALHAMBRA FOR CO SPONSORING THE
BILL WITH LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
AB FIFTEEN FORTY SIX SUPPORT
THE EFFORT AND INTENT OF THE
ALHAMBRA UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT TO ESTABLISH DISTRICT
BASED ELECTIONS BOARD TRUSTEES.
ALIGNED TO THE FAIR AND
DISTRIBUTED REPRESENTATION
PROVISIONS OF THE CALIFORNIA
VOTING RIGHTS ACT. AB FIFTEEN
FORTY SIX ALSO ADDRESS IS A
UNIQUE SITUATION WHERE OUTDATED
REFERENCES IN THE CITY OF
ALHAMBRA CHARTER. RELATED TO
ELECTIONS AT THE ALHAMBRA
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT'S
CONFLICT WITH THE DISTRICT
EFFORT TO ADOPT THE TRUSTEE
AREA ELECTION MODEL. TO ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE AS HE PER THE CITY
PLACE THE MEASURE ON THE BALLOT
IN TWENTY TWENTY TO REMOVE THE
OUTDATED LANGUAGE AND%
REFERENCES TO THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN THEIR CHARTER.
UNFORTUNATELY DUE TO AN ERROR
IN INTERPRETING THE CITY
ELECTION REVOLUTION THAT
MEASURE ONLY APPEARED ON
BALLOTS FOR VOTERS WITHIN THE
CITY OF ALHAMBRA AND DID NOT
APPEAR ON BALLOTS FOR VOTERS.
IN THE SCHOOL DISTRICT TO LIVE
OUTSIDE THE CITY BOUNDARIES
THEREFORE THE MEASURE HAD MUST
BE LACED ON THE BALLOT AGAIN
IN THE FUTURE ELECTION. WAITING
UNTIL THE TWENTY TWENTY TO
STATE GENERAL ELECTION WOULD
DELAY THE DISTRICT EFFORTS TO
ESTABLISH CUT THE AREAS THAT
ALIGN THEIR ELECTIONS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA VOTING RIGHTS ACT.
PRIOR TO THE NEXT ELECTION OF
THE GOVERNING BOARD MEMBERS.
BASED ON THE UNIQUE
CIRCUMSTANCES AND THE
LEGISLATIVE INTENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA VOTING RIGHTS ACT TO
ADVANCE THEIR IN DISTRIBUTED
REPRESENTATION ON LOCAL
GOVERNING BOARDS. THE COUNTY OF
LOS ANGELES RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR I. ABOUT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
MOVING NEXT TO JONATHAN SOUL
FROM EL HAMBRE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND THE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JONATHAN
PAUL AND I'M AN ATTORNEY AT THE
EDUCATION LAW FIRM HAGENS
FRIEDMAN AND PAUL FROST. OUR
FIRM REPRESENTS THE ALHAMBRA
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY. THE DISTRICT IN
CLOSE COLLABORATION WITH THE
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES NVIDIA
HAMBRE IF PLEASED TO CO SPONSOR
AB FIFTEEN FORTY SIX.
YELLOWHAMMER CITY CHARTER
CURRENTLY GOVERNS THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT ELECTIONS AND REQUIRES
THE USE OF AN AT LARGE MATH AT.
THE DISTRICT DESIRE TO
TRANSITION TO A DISTRICT BASED
ELECTIONS SYSTEM SOMETIMES
REFERRED TO AS A BY TRUSTEE
AREA SYSTEM TO ENSURE
COMPLIANCE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
VOTING RIGHTS ACT. IN NOVEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY AT THE DISTRICT'S
REQUEST IF YOU PLACE THE
MEASURE ON THE BALLOT TO REMOVE
ALL REFERENCES TO THE DISTRICT
WITHIN THE CITY CHARTER. THE
PURPOSE OF THE FACTION WITH THE
DE COUPLED WITH THE DISTRICT%
FROM THE CITY CHARTER TO ALLOW
THE DOCTOR TO CONTINUE WITH
THIS TRANSITION FROM AT LARGE
TO BUDGETARY ELECTIONS IN TIME
FOR THE NEXT BOARD OF
EDUCATIONAL EXCELLENCE. IN
NOVEMBER TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
UNFORTUNATELY DUE TO A COUNTY
CLERICAL ERROR THE BALLOT
MEASURE WAS ONLY AVAILABLE TO
CITY RESIDENTS AND NOT YOU ALL
DISTRICT RESIDENTS AS REQUIRED.
UNDER THE CURRENT LAW THE
CHARTER COULD NOT BE MENDED IN
TIME FOR THE DISTRICT TO
COMPLETE ITS TRANSITION AND
HOLD ITS FIRST TRUSTEE AREA
ELECTIONS BY NOVEMBER TWENTY
TWO ELECTIONS RESULTING IN
FURTHER DELAY UNTIL THE
DISTRICTS DESIRED PHOEBE ARE A
COMBINED ELECTION SYSTEM WOULD
BE IMPLEMENTED. ADOPTION OF AB
FIFTEEN FORTY SIX WILL PERMIT
THE CITY TO PLACE AN IDENTICAL
MEASURE ON THE BALLOT. THIS
NOVEMBER AND IF APPROVED ALLOW
THE DISTRICT A COMPLETE
SELECTION TRANSITION. IN A
TIMELY MANNER. ONLY FIFTEEN
DISTRICT ARE IN SYNC COSTA. AND
URGE THAT. I VOTE ON A BEACH IN
FORTY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY. BEAR WITH ME ARE A VERY
WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR IN OPPOSITION TO AB. FIFTEEN
FORTY SIX AS A REMINDER. H. DUE
TO TIME LIMITATIONS FOR THE
COMMITTEE HEARING TODAY THE
PUBLIC WALK FIFTEEN MINUTES IN
TOTAL TIME FOR ADDITIONAL
PUBLIC COMMENT ALL ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES ARE LIMITED BY
WRITING THE NAME THE
ORGANIZATION OF THE REPRESENT
IF ANY IN THE POSITION ON THE
BILL WILL START HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM IS THERE ANYONE
IN THE ROOM WHO WISHES TO
PROVIDE THE POSITION ON AB
FIFTEEN FORTY SIX. SEEING NONE
ANYBODY IN THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION WHO WANTS TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY ON FIFTEEN FORTY SIX.
SEEING NONE. WE WILL NOW OPEN
THE PHONE LINES FOR ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WHO WISH
TO PROVIDE THE POSITION ON AB
THIRTY. FIFTEEN FORTY SIX.
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANYBODY.
ON THE LINE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK
EITHER IN SUPPORT OR IN
OPPOSITION TO AB FIFTEEN FORTY
SIX. WE HAVE SEVERAL LINES Q.
WILL FIRST GO TO LINE FIFTY TWO.
PRESIDENT OF THE ALHAMBRA
SCHOOL DISTRICT BOARD OF
EDUCATION STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL URGING ANTI VOTE FROM THIS
COMMITTEE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. LINE TWENTY FOUR.
HELLO MY NAME IS JOANNE RUSSELL
CHáVEZ A BOARD MEMBER ALL HAVE
A UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT I AM
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN
FORTY SIX THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
LINE SIXTY TWO. HI THIS IS
BRIAN SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS COSPONSOR IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN FORTY SIX
THANK YOU. BLYDE ONE TWENTY
TWO. BY RONCO REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
CLERKS AND ELECTION OFFICIALS
IN SUPPORT. MISTER CHAIRMAN WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE INTO AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WITH
THAT WILL BRING IT BACK TO
COLLEAGUES FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ABOUT THE BILL I
BELIEVE YOU ALREADY HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND REPORT
COMING OUT OF- NOT ORDINARILY I
WOULD RUN. AWAY FROM A CVR A
ISSUE BECAUSE IT'S BEEN A
DISASTER FOR A LOT OF SMALLER
CITIES THAT WERE FORCED TO GO
TO THIS BUT I UNDERSTAND THIS
IS A PRETTY MUCH A MINISTERIAL-
CORRECTION IN THE CITY OF
ALHAMBRA SO JUST LIMITS IT TO
YOUR THAT CITY AND THAT
DISTRICT. SO I'LL BE SUPPORTING
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS MISTER CHAI WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE HI AS PER ADULT
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THIS BILL FIX A AN ACCIDENTAL
ERROR THAT OCCURRED DURING THE
TWENTY TWENTY NOVEMBER GENERAL
ELECTION I APPLAUD THE CITY OF
ALL HAMBRE THE ARBOR UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT. IN THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS FOR COMING TOGETHER
TO RESOLVE THE SITUATION AND
HELP THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
TRANSITION TO A BI DISTRICT
ELECTION METHOD I'M
RECOMMENDING SUPPORT MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE VOTE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BERMAN HI
BERMAN I SAY ARTICLE HI THERE
ARE TWO I BALLOT I FOUND IT ON
A LOW. LOW I MAYES AYE MAYES
AYE MULLIN ONE RUBIO I WANT TO
RUBIO I. THAT IS THE FIRST BILL
RECEIVED AYE VOTES SO FAR. CAN
SIR WE'LL KEEP THE OPEN. HER
BROWN'S MEMBERS. THERE WERE NOW
MOVE ON TO MISTER MAYES SECOND
BILL. AB FOUR FORTY SO. I THINK
THIS CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- DO APPRECIATE OP THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY BEFORE
YOU TODAY ON A. B. FOUR FOUR
SIX IN IN STARTING OFF I REALLY
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- AND ALSO- MISTER JONES
FOR SPENDING HOURS ON THIS ON
THIS BILL- IT JUST HAD TO TAKE
A QUICK ASIDE I'VE ACTUALLY
REALLY APPRECIATED- THE
CONVERSATION AND COMMITTEE
TODAY. APPRECIATED THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT- MISTER
CHAIR UNITED HAD ABOUT THIS
BILL AND WITH STAFF I FEEL LIKE
THIS IS THE WAY THAT ALL OF OUR
COMMITTEES IN THIS- IN THIS
HOUSE SHOULD BE AND SO- AGAIN
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH- I
WILL BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS LISTED IN PARAGRAPH
FOUR FIVE AND SIX. AND SO I
WILL BE SPEAKING ON THIS BILL
AS AS AMENDED. FOR THE ACTIVE
VOTING IS OUR MOST POWERFUL
FORM OF FREE SPEECH. OUR
FOUNDERS ENVISIONED A SYSTEM OF
REPRESENTATIVE DEMOCRACY WHERE
INDIVIDUALS COULD SPEAK
COLLECTIVELY. TO ELECT THOSE
WHO BEST REPRESENTED THEIR
POLITICAL AND PHILOSOPHICAL
PREFERENCES. WELL A FLURRY OF
POLITICAL PARTIES MARKET
NATION'S INFANCY SINCE THE
EIGHTEEN FIFTIES ELECTIONS HAVE
BEEN DOMINATED BY JUST TWO
PARTIES. CALIFORNIA LAW GIVES
IMMENSE IMMENSE ADVANTAGES TO
EXISTING ORGANIZED POLITICAL
PARTIES. WHAT CREATING MULTIPLE
BARRIERS THAT IMPEDE NEW
MOVEMENTS. AS NOTED IN THE
ANALYSIS SINCE NINETEEN SIXTY
EIGHT ONLY SEVEN NEW POLITICAL%
PARTIES OF QUALIFIED TO
PARTICIPATE IN CALIFORNIA
ELECTIONS. WITH SIX PARTIES
QUALIFYING THROUGH VOTER
REGISTRATION AND ONLY ONE
QUALIFYING. THROUGH THE
PETITION PROCESS BUT THEY
FAILED TO STOP AT THE STATE
QUALIFY FOR SUBSEQUENT
ELECTIONS. WHEN THEY FAILED TO
REGISTER ENOUGH VOTERS. OUR TWO
PARTY SYSTEM DOES NOT REFLECT
CALIFORNIA'S CURRENT POLITICAL
MAKE UP. CALLS FOR NEW OPTIONS
REVERBERATE THROUGH THE BASE OF
BOTH PARTIES AND A GROWING
NUMBER OF CALIFORNIANS DO NOT
IDENTIFY. WITH EITHER. AS
AMENDED THIS BILL WOULD REDUCE
THE NUMBER OF SIGNATURES NEEDED
ON A PETITION TO FORM A NEW
POLITICAL PARTY FROM TEN
PERCENT. 5% PUTTING CALIFORNIAN
LINE WITH MOST OTHER STATES.
THIS BILL ALSO SEEKS TO FORGET
NAMES A PRIOR UNSUCCESSFUL
POLITICAL MOVEMENTS BY ALLOWING
A NEW POLITICAL BODY. TO
REGISTER WITH THE NAME IT HAS
BEEN ABANDONED FOR MORE THAN
TWO YEARS. IT'S IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT IT IS DIFFICULT TO
GET A FULL RECORD OF PRIOR
ATTEMPTS BY POLITICAL BODIES TO
QUALIFYBECAUSE- A SUBSTANTIAL
PORTION OF THESE RECORDS ARE ON
PAPER ARCHIVES. SO ONE MAY NOT
EVEN KNOW A SIMILAR EFFORT WAS
MADE IN THE PAST INTO THE APPLY
TO SECRETARY OF STATE. STATE
LAW REQUIRES THE SECRETARY TO
REJECT THE USE OF A POLITICAL
PARTY NAME IF IT HAS EVER BEEN
USED OR IS EVEN SIMILAR TO A
NAME PROPOSED BY ANY PRIOR
POLITICAL BODY. TO ENSURE THAT
VOTERS REGISTERING WITH THE NEW
POLITICAL BODY REFLECT DEVISE A
PRIOR MOVEMENTS WITH TE NOW
ABANDONED NAME. THIS BILL WOULD
ONLY ALLOW REGISTRATION SIGN IN
THE YEAR TO THE OFFICIAL EFFORT
TO COUNT TOWARDS THE POINT 33%
VOTER REGISTRATION
REQUIREMENTS. LASTLY THIS BILL
FORMALIZES SECRETARY STATE
PROCEDURES FOR AN APPEALS
PROCESS. WHEN APPLYING FOR A
POLITICAL PARTY NAME- I
UNDERSTAND THE LAST WEEK WE
RECEIVED A SUPPORT OPPOSITION
LETTER INCLUDING. COMMENTS ON
THE FIVE FOR THRESHOLD WHICH
WAS REMOVED FROM THE BILL. WHAT
WE DID INITIALLY PROPOSED THIS
CHANGE THAT WE AGREED TO REMOVE
IT- WITH THAT WITH OUR
CONVERSATIONS- AND THERE'S SOME
ISSUES THERE- AT THAT TIME
THERE WAS NO SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION ON THE BILL- AS THIS
MEASURE IS- IS OFFICE
SPONSORED- I LOOK FORWARD. TO
HAVING SOME DISCUSSIONS I DON'T
HAVE ANYBODY ELSE- HERE TO
TALK. SO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
PERFECT. THANK YOU MISTER
MAYES- WITH THAT WE WILL MOVE
TO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION I HAVE- CT FIRST CD
WEBER WITH THE PEACE AND
FREEDOM PARTY OF CALIFORNIA.
AND AS A REMINDER YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES FOR OPPOSITION
TESTIMONY AND THEN WE'LL MOVE
ON- TO MY FEINSTEIN. HI MY NAME
IS SIKI WEBER I'M HE
LEGISLATIVE PLACED ON FOR PEACE
AND FREEDOM PARTY OF
CALIFORNIA. WHEN AB FOUR FOUR
SIX FIRST INTRODUCED. THE
FREEDOM PARTY VOTED TO SUPPORT
IT. BECAUSE IT MADE IT EASIER
FOR NEW PARTIES TO QUALIFY FOR
THE BALLOT. AFTER PARTIES
MAINTAIN THEIR BALLOT STATUS.
HAVE YOU EVER SUPPORTED AND
IDEAS THAT. DIDN'T WORK BECAUSE
OF UNFORESEEN CONSEQUENCES.
WELL THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THE
RECENTLY AMENDED AB FOUR FOUR
SIX THE- IT IS BASED ON A GOOD
IDEA PROVIDING MORE CHOICES.
HOWEVER AN IMPORTANT PILLAR OF
THIS BILL WAS REMOVED. THE PART
THAT MADE IT JUST AS EASY TO
MAINTAIN BALLOT STATUS AS IT
WAS TO QUALIFY IN THE FIRST
PLACE. HISTORICALLY THERE HAS
BEEN A SATURATION POINT WHERE
NOT ALL THE BALLOT QUALIFIED
PARTIES WERE ABLE TO SURVIVE.
SO IF YOU MAKE IT EASY. TO
QUALIFY COMMONSENSE DICTATE BUT
YOU ALSO MAKE IT EASIER TO
MAINTAIN BALLOT STATUS. UNDER
AB FOUR FOUR SIX IF I KNEW
PARTY WERE TO QUALIFY FOR THE
BALLOT BY GETTING THE
SIGNATURES OF 3% OF THE NUMBER
OF VOTERS WHO VOTED IN THE LAST
FIFTEEN GUBERNATORIAL ELECTION.
THEN IT'S CANDIDATES FAIL TO
GET THE 2% OF THE VOTE FOR
STATEWIDE RACES WITHOUT POINT
33% OF THE TOTAL REGISTRATION
THIS NEW PARTY WOULD LOSE ITS
BALLOT STATUS. THE GREEN PARTY.
HAS OFFERED IT'S SUPPORT EIGHTY
FOUR FOUR SIX AMENDED TO LOWER
THE FILING SEASON THE
SIGNATURES IN LIEU OF THE
FUNDING FEE. AND TO LOWER THE
COST FOUR STATE AND COUNTY
VOTER INFORMATION GUIDES WE
AGREE ACCEPT OUR PROPOSALS ARE
TO ELIMINATE. FILING SEASON
SIGNATURES A LITTLE POLICIES
ENTIRELY BECAUSE THEY ARE
UNCONSTITUTIONAL HER LIVING
VERSUS SPANISH. AND REMOVE THE
TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS THE WORD
SHE TO HAVE A STATEMENT ON THE
OFFICIAL VOTERS THAT PROMOTION
GUIDE IS THE RESULT OF A POISON
PILL AND- PROPOSITION THIRTY
FOUR. BEFORE TWO THOUSAND THERE
IS NO CHARGE FOR THE STATEMENTS.
WE RECOMMEND THE FATHER WORKED
WITH THE- BODIES AND- HAVE IN
THE BILL APPROPRIATELY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OUR
NEXT WE HAVE MIKE FEINSTEIN
WITH THE GREEN PARTY OF LOS
ANGELES COUNTY WHICH HAS A
SUPPORT IF AMENDED- BOAT BUT
WERE- ARE ARE. BEING TREATED AS
A SECOND OPPOSITION WHEN THIS
FOR THE PURPOSES OF THE TIME
ALLOTTED FOR CURRENT WITNESSES
SAY OF TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU
DEAR CHAIR BERMAN AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS MICHAEL
FEINSTEIN I'M A CO FOUNDER OF
THE GREEN PARTY OF CALIFORNIA.
A FORMER MAYOR AND CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER IN SANTA MONICA AND A
TWENTY EIGHTEEN CANDIDATE FOR
SECRETARY OF STATE. THE GREEN
PARTY THE LOS ANGELES
SACRAMENTO COUNTY SUPPORT
EIGHTY FOUR FORTY SIX WITH
AMENDMENTS. WE APPLIED ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MAYES IN ITS EFFORT TO
PROVIDE A MORE REASONABLE
PETITION SIGNATURE OUT TO
QUALIFY FOR STATE PARTY BALLOT
STATUS. AT THE EXISTING
THRESHOLD IS AMONG THE MOST
ONEROUS IN THE NATION. THIS IS
A PRIMARY REASON WE SUPPORT
EIGHTY FOUR FORTY SIX.
IRONICALLY AT THE SAME TIME YOU
CAN BE EASIER FOR PARTIES TO
QUALIFY FOR BALLOT STATUS. IT
WILL REMAIN VIRTUALLY
IMPOSSIBLE FOR THEM TO RUN
CANDIDATES. TOP TWO ELECTION
REQUIREMENTS THAT MADE IT DE
FACTO IMPOSSIBLE FOR SMALLER
PARTY CANDIDATES TO ADVANCE TO
THE GENERAL ELECTION EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT TO EVEN APPEAR ON THE
PRIMARY. BEFORE TALK TO
CALIFORNIA'S FOR LEGACY SMALLER
PARTIES EVERY TO ONE HUNDRED
AND TWENTY SEVEN CANDIDATES.
AND EACH PRIMARY BALLOT EVER
SINCE ONLY THIRTY NINE OF THEIR
CANDIDATES IN TOTAL HAVE
QUALIFIED EIGHT ELECTION MAKING
CALIFORNIA A MULTI PARTY
DEMOCRACY IN NAME ONLY. THAT'S
WHY AB FOR FORTY SIX SHOULD BE
AMENDED TO SUBSTANTIALLY LOWER
OUR STATE OUT OF DATE FOR
FILING TO BE A SIGNATURE IN THE
THRESHOLD. THAT WAS CREATED
WHEN WAS MOSTLY ONLY MAJOR
PARTIES ON THE BALLOT. BEFORE
TWENTY OH TO VOTER CANDIDATE A
VOTER GUIDE CANDID STATEMENTS
WERE FREE SINCE THEN THEY HAVE
BEEN RAISED TO A PER CAPITA
COSTS. FOR THE SAME CANDIDATES
MANY VOTERS RECEIVE ALMOST NO
INFORMATION ABOUT MANY OF THE
CHOICES BEFORE THEM FOR THAT
REASON AB FOUR FORTY SIX SHOULD
BE AMENDED TO MAKE THAT CAUGHT
THE MINIMUS. GREEN SUPPORT A
FULL RANGE OF PARTIES ON THE
BALLOT THAT REFLECT THE
DIVERSITY OF POLITICAL
VIEWPOINTS WITHIN CALIFORNIA.
AND ELECTORAL SYSTEM THAT
ALLOWS THEM ALL THE RUN
PUNITIVE. AND WIND SPEEDS IN
PROPORTION TO THE PERCENTAGE OF
THE POPULAR VOTE. THAT IS THE
REASON YOU. SHOULD CONVENE A
DEEP PUBLIC CRY THE TO REVIEW
THE TOP TWO X. AND ALL. TO IT
INCLUDING PER EVAN. OUT OF THE
MONEY YEAR. AND RANCHO VOTING
FOR SINGLE THE BIG WHITE ARE.
THANK THANK VERY MUCH. WE WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB AT FOUR FORTY
SIX. AS A REMINDER DUE TO TIME
LIMITATIONS FOR THE COMMITTEE
HEARING TODAY THE PUBLIC WALK
FIFTEEN MINUTES IN TOTAL TIME
FOR ADDITIONAL PUBLICCOMMENT.
ALL ADDITIONAL WITNESSES ARE
LIMITED TO PROVIDING THEIR
NAMES THE ORGANIZATIONS THAT
THEY REPRESENT AND THE POSITION
ON THE BILL. IF ANY. OUR
WHATEVER YOU GET IT. WE WILL
START HERE IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM. IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
ROOM WHO WISHES TO PROVIDE
THEIR POSITION ON AB FOR FORTY
SIX. C. NINE. WILL KICK IT OVER
TO REMOTE TO TESTIMONY STATION
ANYBODY. SAYING NONE. WE WILL
NOW OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WHICH
PROVIDE THE POSITION ON EIGHTY
FOUR FORTY SIX. MODERATOR DO WE
HAVE ANYBODY ON THE LINE WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK EITHER IN
SUPPORT OR IN OPPOSITION. THEY
BEFORE. FORTY SIX. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FOR COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO A. B.
FOUR FOUR SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
AT THE END OF THE ROW. THAT
COMMAND AGAIN ONE SEVEN ZERO.
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO COMMENT
COMING THROUGH AT THE TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BRING BACK
A COLLEAGUES FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS OR MOTIONS ARE SECONDS
I DON'T RECALL VIA MOTION OR
SECOND EARLIER. STILL LOOKING
FOR MOTION OR SECOND OR ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. NOT
SEEING ANY OF THAT- WE'VE GOT A
MOTION WE HAVE A SECOND MISTER
MAYES WE LIKE TO CLOSE. SURE
THIS IS A INTERESTING
CONVERSATION DID HAVE A LITTLE
DIALOGUE EARLIER WITH ONE OF
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS ON IT-
YOU KNOW I AS- AS IT'S WIDELY
KNOWN- I GAVE UP MY- PARTY
REGISTRATION- AND I AM AN
INDEPENDENT BUT IF I AM
COMPLETELY HONEST AND
TRANSPARENT- IF IT WAS UP TO
ME- I WOULD DO AWAY WITH OUR
PARTIES. ALTOGETHER I AM NOT SO
FOOLISH AS TO BELIEVE THAT THAT
IS- IS GOING TO HAPPEN- A BUT-
AS THE FORMER REPUBLICAN LEADER
IN THE ASSEMBLY AND WHO
SOMEBODY HAD TO WORK WITHIN THE
PARTY AT THE PARTY SYSTEM- I
CAN TELL YOU THAT THERE ARE.
INCREDIBLE ADVANTAGES- TO
HAVING THEM A POLITICAL PARTY I
AND FOR CANDIDATES WHO ARE NOT
OUT ONE OF THE ONE OF THE TWO
ARE EVEN INVOLVED WITH ONE OF
THE OTHERS IT'S EVEN MORE
DIFFICULT. I TO BE ABLE TO- TO
HAVE TO HAVE ACCESS. A
CALIFORNIA BACK TO VERY PROUD
THAT WE DO HAVE A THE OPEN
PRIMARY- I KNOW THAT THERE ARE
SOME CITIES THAT ALSO HAVE A
RANK CHOICE VOTING WE HAVE.
DONE AN INCREDIBLE AMOUNT SO TO
BE ABLE TO ALLOW FOR A MORE
DEMOCRACY IN THE STATE OF THE
MEASURE BEFORE YOU TODAY- IS-
IS GOES UP ALONG THAT SAME LINE
JUST ALLOWED A LITTLE EASIER.
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE- OTHER
MOVEMENTS- TO BE ABLE TO GET
STARTED BUT IT'S STILL A VERY
VERY HIGH THRESHOLD- HOWEVER-
IT IS- GOES A LONG WAY TOWARDS
ALLOWING A FOR NEW MOVEMENTS TO
BE ABLE TO START SO AGAIN I
WANT TO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
FOR ALL OF YOUR- A YOUR HELP ON
THIS- AND THE COMMITTEE'S WORK.
AND I WOULD APPRECIATE WORKING
WITH YOU GUYS THIS IS FILLED
WITH FORD THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER MASON I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR WORKING WITH ME AND
COMMITTEE STAFF ON AMENDMENTS
TO THIS BILL I APPRECIATE THE
UNIQUE PERSPECTIVE THAT YOU
BRING ON THIS ISSUE GIVEN THAT
YOU WERE THE FIRST PERSON TO BE
ELECTED TO THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE IN MORE THAN TWENTY
YEARS. WITH NEITHER A DEMOCRAT
NOR A REPUBLICAN WHEN APPEARING
ON THE BALLOT I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL WITH THE
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE DETAILED IN
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AND THAT
HAVE BEEN ACCEPTED BY THE
AUTHOR. WITH THAT MADAM
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE VOTE.
THE IS TO PAY. A SOME. AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE APPROACH.
BERMAN HI. BERMAN I SAY ARE
TôI FAIR TRIAL I'D DONE IT.
BENNETT IS NOT VOTING LOW.
HELLO I MAYES. MAYES AYE MULLIN
MULLIN AYE BLANCA RUBIO I WANT
TO REVEAL ON. THAT BILL IS OUT
ON A SIX ZERO VOTE IF I HAVE MY
MATH CORRECT I DO I'M NOT GOING
TO TURN IT OVER TO THE MESSAGE
YOU HAVE THE SCRIPT EVERYTHING
I DO I'M PERMITTED TO GO ON A
ROLL AND ALL THAT. STUFF BUT DO
IT. ALL RIGHT THE NEXT ITEM ON
THE IS AB FOURTEEN NINETY FIVE
I SIMPLY MEMBER BERMAN AS SOON
AS YOU GET DOWN OF THE PODIUM
YOU'RE READY TO GO. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. MISTER CHAIRMAN
COLLEAGUES OF. ONE COMELEC
HARRIS RESIGNED HER U. S.
SENATE SEAT IN ADVANCE OF BEING
SWORN IN AS VICE PRESIDENT IN
JANUARY. IT CREATED A VACANCY
IN CALIFORNIA'S REPRESENTATION
IN THE U. S. SENATE FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN THIRTY YEARS.
THAT VACANCY IN THE SUBSEQUENT
APPOINTMENT OF THEN SECRETARY
OF STATE ALEX PADILLA TO THE U.
S. SENATE. PROMPTED A RE
EXAMINATION OF CALIFORNIA'S
LAWS GOVERNING THE FILLING OF
THE U. S. SENATE VACANCIES.
BECAUSE SENATOR PER DEAL WAS
APPOINTED TO A TERM THAT ENDS
ON JANUARY THIRD FOLLOWING THE
NEXT REGULARLY SCHEDULED
STATEWIDE. GENERAL ELECTION.
EXISTING STATE LAW ALLOWS HIM
TO REMAIN IN OFFICE UNTIL THE
CONCLUSION OF THAT TERM. ON
JANUARY THIRD TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. AS A COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
POINTS OUT HOWVER. TO FEDERAL
APPELLATE COURT OPINIONS ISSUED
SINCE TWO THOUSAND TEN HAVE
RAISED QUESTIONS ABOUT WHETHER
THAT ASPECT OF STATE LAW
COMPLIES WITH THE SEVENTEENTH
AMENDMENT. TO THE U. S.
CONSTITUTION. ADDITIONALLY
STATE LAW DOES NOT PROVIDE A
WORKABLE SITUATION FOR FILLING
U. S. SENATE VACANCIES. IN
OTHER SITUATIONS FOR EXAMPLE
STATE LAW APPEARS TO REQUIRE.
THAT ELECTION BE HELD TO FILL A
VACANCY AT A STATEWIDE GENERAL
ELECTION. EVEN IF THE VACANCY
OCCURS THE DAY BEFORE THE
ELECTION. MAYBE FOURTEEN NINETY
FIVE AND FOR THE CALIFORNIA LAW
IS CONSISTENT WITH THE SEVENTY
THE MOMENT. BY PROVIDING FOR AN
ELECTION TO BE HELD TO FILL A
VACANCY IN CALIFORNIA'S.
REPRESENTATION IN THE U. S.
SENATE. EVEN IF THE VACANCY
OCCURS DURING THE LAST TWO
YEARS OF THE U. S. SENATE TERM.
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THE GREATEST
PARTICIPATION IN THOSE
ELECTIONS. AND TO AVOID THE
COSTS AND DISRUPTIONS OF
STANDALONE STATEWIDE SPECIAL
ELECTIONS WHENEVER POSSIBLE. AB
FOURTEEN NINETY FIVE GENERALLY
REQUIRES U. S. SENATE VACANCY
ELECTIONS. TO BE CONSOLIDATED
WITH REGULARLY SCHEDULED.
STATEWIDE ELECTIONS. WHERE THAT
IS NOT POSSIBLE THIS BILL ALSO
ESTABLISHES A PROCEDURE FOR THE
GOVERNOR TO SCHEDULE A
STATEWIDE SPECIAL ELECTION. TO
FILL THE VACANCY IF IT IS THE
PRACTICAL IF IT IS PRACTICAL TO
DO SO. BEFORE THE END OF THE
TERM. IF YOU FOURTEEN NINETY
FIVE IS SUPPORTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS AND S. YEAH
YOU CALIFORNIA AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. PHONE. THANK
YOU MA'AM. THE MOTION IS ARE
THE BILL IS THE MOVE BY MR LOW
AND SECONDED BY MR MAYES. SO
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO THE
PRIMARY WITNESS IN. SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL AND THAT WILL BE
MELISSA MA FROM THE- MELISSA
ROMERO. FROM CALIFORNIA LEAGUE
OF CONSERVATION VOTERS. WE HAVE
MELISSA MISS MIRAMAR ONLINE.
YEAH THERE WE GO AHEAD WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CONCEPT CONSERVATION
VOTERS PROUD TO SUPPORT THE
NUMBER BERMAN AT FOURTEEN
NINETY FIVE NOT ONLY IS THIS
BILL IMPORTANT FOR THE FACT
THAT CALIFORNIA LAW NEEDS TO BE
BROUGHT INTO COMPLIANCE WITH
THE U. S. CONSTITUTION. THIS
BILL WILL ENSURE THAT WHENEVER
THERE IS A VACANCY IN THE U. S.
SENATE SEAT CALIFORNIANS HAVE
ACCESS TO THE MARKET THE END.
OF BOYS AND REPRESENT THAT.
THANK YOU FOR CALLING IN THE US
SENATE CREDIT DECISION THAT YOU
CALL. ALL DESERVE TO HAVE FANS
EXACTLY CONSIDERING THE FACT
THAT HELP SO- ONLY HAS. BEEN
BURKE IS A BEACON. I POINT
WHENEVER. YOU KNOW STATE
PARKWAY IN NEW SENATE I NORMAL
POPULATION TO MOST SPACE. FOR
HAVE TO GO. A AND GET. WHO
REPRESENT POLICY. U. S. WHAT
MUCH MORE. THAT YOU INDIVIDUAL
VOTER ANY NOT SURE THAT WE DO
NOT. PRODUCTIVITY IN THE BLACK.
RIGHT RIGHT. FEDERAL STATE WIDE
ELECTION YOU HAVE MY HIGHER A
FIFTY RATE. INCLUDING ALLOW AT.
MORE REPRESENTS. OF THE POPULAR
AND THE BIRTH. AND THINK BY.
ACTION. THE BY REQUIRE ELECTION
BE HELD THE BUILDER OF THE U.
S. SENATE TERM IF THEY CAN BE.
AND ABOUT. INDICATES THAT IT'S
NOT TO DO THAT EIGHTY FOUR
TWENTY INSURANCE CALIFORNIA'S
DO NOT NOT REPRESENT. IN THE U.
S. SENATE. IN CALIFORNIA
COMBINED TO BE LESS
CONSTITUTION ENACTED BY THE
VOTER ACCESS ACCORDING TO
COMPLEXION THE THING TIME
REGULAR. STATEWIDE PRIMARY AND
ELECTIONS POSSIBLE. FURTHERMORE
U. S. THEY CAN ELECT OF SAME
KIND OF REGULAR SCHEDULED
STATEWIDE ELECTION. ENSURE THAT
THERE AMPLE. FOR TO BE
ETHICALLY AND CANADA SHOULDN'T
BE IT'S WHAT THE- COMPANY
FRIEDMAN BILL FOR THE PRODUCT
COURT AT FOURTEEN FIVE. AND
THIRTY SIX I. LIMITATIONS IN
THE COMMITTEE'S HEARING TODAY
WE'RE GOING TO LIMIT THESE THAT
THE PUBLIC WILL HAVE FIFTEEN
MINUTES TOTAL TIME. FOR
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC COMMENT. SO
AND ALSO DURING PUBLIC COMMENT
JUST STATE YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND WHETHER YOU
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE. AND THAT
WILL HELP. OTHERS TO BE ABLE TO
GET ON THE LINE ALSO. SO
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE THE ANY
CALLERS ON THE LINE. FOUR
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO A BE FOURTEEN
NINETY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. COMMAND AGAIN
ONE AT THAT ZERO AND A LINE OF
ONE HUNDRED THIRTY YEAR MIKE IT
UP- AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS ROSLYN BOLD ENOUGH BOTH
THE ASIAN OF LATINO ELECTED AND
APPOINTED OF BACK UNVEILED.
KEIICHI BOND OUT SUPPORT FORTY
NINETY FIVE AND- URGE YOU TO
VOTE IT OUT OF COMMITTEE THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU MA'AM
NEXT WEEK- PLEASE. AND MEDICARE
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT
THE TIME ALL RIGHT SO WE'LL
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ROOM IF THERE'S ANYBODY IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK ON THIS IT DOESN'T
LOOK LIKE ANYBODY'S THERE. ARE
WE CAN LOOK AT THE REMOTE
LOCATION THEY LOOK LIKE
ANYBODY'S THERE SO WILL BRING
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. I AM VERY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS GOING ONCE GOING TWICE
OKAY. MR BERMAN YOU CAN CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH INTEREST
AHRI MISS SECRETARY CAN CALL
THE ROLL THE MOST. START THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN HI BERMAN
I SAY ARTICLE NO SE ARE TELL NO
BENEFITS. SENATE I LOW. HELLO
IMA. MAYES ON MY- MULLIN I
BOUGHT RUBIO NINE ONE PER I.
ALL RIGHT THAT THE TO ONE ITEM
PASSES ON ONE. AND THAT BRINGS
US TO THE ITEM WHICH IS A. B.
FIFTEEN NINETY AND MR BERMAN
AGAIN YOU'RE GOING TO BE
PRESENTING ON THIS SO- YOU MAY
BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY. FACT
WELL MOTION BY LAW A SECOND BY.
MR MAYES GO AHEAD THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN COLLEAGUES REAL
SHORT HERE EVERY FIFTEEN NINETY
IS ONE OF THE ASSEMBLY
ELECTIONS COMMITTEES AND YOU ON
THE BEST BILLS. CONTAINING
MINOR AND NON CONTROVERSIAL
CHANGES TO THE POLITICAL REFORM
ACT THIS BILL INCLUDES CHANGES
TO STATE LAW THAT WERE
REQUESTED BY THE FAIR POLITICAL
PRACTICES COMMISSION AND OTHER
TECHNICAL CHANGES IDENTIFIED BY
COMMITTEE STAFF. SB FIFTY
NINETY IS SUPPORTED BY THE FAIR
POLITICAL PRACTICES COMMISSION
AND HAS NO OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
RESPECT AFTER RIVAL. ALL RIGHT
THAT BRINGS US TO. AND PEOPLE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS TO BE A
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT WE
HAVE ONE IT LOOKS LIKE- MISS
LINDSAY AN ECONOMY. WENDY WHEN
YOU'RE READY YOU MAY BEGIN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR A GOOD
AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS LINDA MCCONNELL AND I'M
LEGISLATIVE COUNCIL FOR THE
FAIR POLITICAL PRACTICES
COMMISSION. YES YOU CAN SEE THE
STATE COMMISSION THAT
ADMINISTERS AND ENFORCES THE
POLITICAL REFORM ACT WHICH
REGULATE CAMPAIGN FINANCING
CONFLICT OF INTEREST LOBBYING
AND GOVERNMENTAL ETHICS.
COMMISSION IS PLEASED TO
SUPPORT EIGHTY FIFTEEN NINETY
UNDER EXISTING LAW A POLITICAL
COMMITTEE IS REQUIRED TO PAY A
FIFTY DOLLAR ANNUAL FEE TO THE
SECRETARY OF STATE AND FAILURE
TO TIMELY PAY THAT FEE IS
SUBJECT TO A ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
DOLLAR PENALTY. PORTION IS
CURRENTLY REQUIRED TO ENFORCE
THE PROVISION. THE QUESTION WAS
RAISED. IN A PRIOR PUBLIC.
BILLETE FORM FORCING THAT
PROVISION TO THE SECRETARY OF
STATE- BY ELIMINATING THE
COMMISSION'S ROLE IN A- THE
PROPOSAL WASN'T IN THE BILL AT
THE REQUEST OF THE COMMISSION I
WANT THANK. FOR THE FIRST
CENTERS THIS. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MR MCCONNELL. SO
BRING THIS AN OP. WHAT WERE
YOURS IS LISTED. SO IT THIS
TIME GONNA GO AND MOVE TO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION OF A. B. FIFTEEN
NINETY AND AS A REMINDER YOU
HAVE ABOUT FIFTEEN MINUTES
TOTAL TIME FOR SPEAKERS. AND
I'M NOT GONNA GO INTO THE REST
BECAUSE IT PROBABLY WON'T BE
CALLED. SO THE MODERATOR DO WE
HAVE ANY SPEAKERS ON THE LINE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO AB FIFTEEN NINETY
PLEASE PRESS ONE THE BUREAU
THAT COMMAND AGAIN. ONE SEVEN
ZERO. MEDICARE WE HAVE NO
COMMENT AT THIS TIME WHAT A
SURPRISE ANYWAY NEXT UP WE HAVE
THE THAT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ROOM AND I DON'T SEE ANYBODY IN
THE COMMITTEE ROOM AND WE DON'T
HAVE ANYBODY IN THE REMOTE
LOCATION. SO THAT BRINGS IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ITSELF
ANYBODY HAVE ANY COMMENTS
QUESTIONS CONCERNS YOU LIKE
EXPRESSED IT IS THE MR BERMAN.
BEING AN MISTER BIRMINGHAM
CLOSE. RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL
THING MR. THE SECOND MAKE ROLE.
THE MOST IS TO PASS BERMAN HI
BERMAN I SAY ARE TELLING SAY
ARCHER IS VOTE BAN. SENATE OUR
LOW LOW I AS. MAYES AYE MULLIN
MULLIN- WELCOME. CAN WE OPEN
THE ROLE FOR ABSENT MEMBERS-
OPEN THE CALL OR WHATEVER THE
PROPER TERMINOLOGY IS. FOUR
PEOPLE AND ON THE BILL'S OF
THEIR OUT OF THE CHAMBERS FOR
ADD ONS AND AB SEVEN FIVE NINE
MCCARTY THE MOTION WAS TO PASS
IN REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS. THE
CHAIR VOTING ARE MULLIN. MULLIN
I. I THEM FOR AB FORTY SIX BY
TWO THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
TO RESULT IN ALL MULLIN. MORE I.
YEAH ADAM FOR A BI TWENTY MAY
THE MOTION IS TO PASS WITH THE
TERRIBLE I MULLIN MULLIN. HELLO
HAVE. YOU GET ON. DOES THAT
WELL I MULLIN. THANK MULLIN I
BLANCA RUBIO BLANCA RUBIO I.
THANK YOU- AND WITH THAT THE
HEARING IS ADJOURNED. THE RED
PARTY BILL.